Musik So, ich würde sagen, wir fangen heute mal ganz ordentlich mit einer feinen Anmoderation an, klare, deutliche Worte, die den Zuschauer begrüssen und in ein warmes Bett einbetten. Bitteschön. Herzlich willkommen zum Podcast-UFO, die Folge drei. Wir haben jetzt Dienstag, den 23. Dezember, morgen ist Heiligabend. Nicht wie viele sagen Weihnachten, morgen ist Heiligabend.
Und wir haben echt eine volle Sendung für euch, wir haben hammergeile Themen. Ich habe das erste schon wieder vergessen, deines waren Mails, glaube ich, du hast dir Mails ausgesucht als Thema. Ja, du hast auch schon wieder vergessen, uns anzuholen. Ach, die kennen uns so mittlerweile, die klicken uns so nicht an und wissen nicht, wer wir sind. Du bist Florentin Will, du bist sowas wieder der aufstrebendste Jungmoderator deines Wohnviertels. Und ich bin, ja, mir ist es egal, ich bin dir einfach egal. Du hast heute eine sehr schöne Stimme, wenn ich dir das mal sage. Du hast heute so etwas sehr Relaxendes. Ja, ich war gestern ein bisschen feiern und habe geraucht ohne Ende. Oh, wirklich? Was denn? Ne, ich war nur ein paar Freunde, habe Glühwein trinken ein bisschen. Um die Situation mal ein bisschen näher zu beleuchten. Wir machen ja ein kreatives Produkt hier und versuchen uns ständig zu verbessern. Und ich habe herausgefunden, durch meine lange Erfahrung, die einzige Möglichkeit, ein kreatives Produkt wirklich gut zu machen, ist, Kritikimmunität herzustellen. Man muss ein Produkt schaffen, das sich nicht kritisieren lässt, nur dadurch wird es gut. Wie erreichen wir diese Kritikimmunität? Selbstironie. Selbstironie sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr. Und zwar, wir haben jetzt drei Folgen gemacht und wir haben jede Folge an einem anderen Ort aufgenommen.
Die erste Folge im Studio, die zweite Folge bei uns in den Wohnungen über Skype und jetzt sind wir alle wieder in unseren Kinderstuben, weil ja morgen Heiligabend ist.
Das heißt, wir können immer die Qualität der Folge auf den Aufnahmeort schieben.
Wir müssen es nie tatsächlich an uns heranlassen. Wir können nur sagen, ja, war halt ein bisschen blöd, der Raum ist ein bisschen größer, halliger, hier und da. Und dadurch werden wir im Endeffekt immer besser, weil wir nie Kritik zulassen können. Ich finde es irgendwie, ich glaube, da müsste eigentlich diese Folge die schlechteste sein, weil ich bin hier mitten am Land und es kann gut sein, dass gleich irgendwie so ein Trecker vorbeikommt und irgendwie so ultralange braucht, um hier vorbeizufahren und man mich für zehn Minuten nicht hört einfach oder dass irgendwie ein Maulwurf die Internetleitung kappt. Kann auch gut sein. Und was wir tatsächlich auch immer machen, ist wir nehmen zu anderen Zeiten auf. Ich bin zum Beispiel gerade eben erst aufgestanden, bin vor einer halben Stunde aufgewacht, habe mir jetzt eine Schüssel Cornflakes reingezogen und sitze jetzt hier. Das habe ich noch nie gemacht, direkt nach dem Aufstehen zu Podcasten. Das fällt auch nicht so gut. Aber wir können es wieder auf die Tageszeit schieben dann. Absolut, das ist ja. Ich fand die Folge nicht so gut. Ja, wir haben ja auch sehr früh aufgenommen. Aber damit das nicht passiert, haben wir natürlich eine Menge fette Themen für euch vorbereitet. Stefan Titzel hatte schon, naja, sagen wir jetzt mal unterdurchschnittlich gut angeteasert. Und zwar haben wir heute das Thema Mails, E-Mails. Wir benutzen sie tagtäglich, aber dennoch schlummert in ihnen eine fantastische Magie, die wir heute komediantisch auslöffeln werden, bis nichts mehr da ist. Und das zweite Thema hat sich Stefan ausgesucht. Magnete. Magnete. Das sind die, im Gegensatz zu Mails, stecken wirklich voller Geheimnisse und die sind wahnsinnig anziehend, ein anziehendes Thema. Aber tatsächlich, ich glaube, ich halte mich für einen relativ klugen Gesellen und ich glaube, ich kann auch relativ viele Dinge verstehen. Aber es gibt so manche Dinge, wo ich einfach schon relativ früh beschlossen habe, ich werde einfach nie verstehen, wie das funktioniert. Und dazu gehört eindeutig Magnet. Ja, das finde ich auch. Das ist einfach so undurchdringbar. Ich werde es nie verstehen. Und was ich dabei nicht verstehe, ist, dass es so wenig gebraucht wird. Also gefühlt steckt da ein unfassbar großes Potenzial dahinter, hinter Magneten. Allein sich fortzubewegen, hier Magnetschwebebahn und so. Und es wird einfach, glaube ich, ich kenne mich da auch nicht so aus, aber es wird nicht so viel damit gemacht. Und dann habe ich mir überlegt, man könnte die auch in verschiedenen Tagessituationen, könnte man Magnete gut gebrauchen. Da vielleicht auch später zu mehr. Ich glaube, Magnete stecken zu grosses Potential, also um da nichts mehr zu machen. Also, es ist einmal so generell, wie ein Magnet funktioniert, verstehe ich schon, aber trotzdem ist es so strange. Ja. Also das ist einfach so komisch, vor allem, ich denke mir, die sind ja sozusagen, die haben ja kein Limit, also die sind ja ständig magnetisch anziehungshaftraft. Da muss eine riesen Energie drin stecken. Die haben ständig eine Kraft aus, ohne dass sie ihre Energie verlieren. Also du kannst ja meinetwegen so dieses klassische Faden an der Nadel und dann schwebt die Nadel so in der Luft auf den Magnet hin. Ja, aber die muss ja schon mal größer als die Gravitationskraft sein. Zum Beispiel, aber vor allem das hört ja nicht auf. Ich meine, wahrscheinlich hören die schon irgendwann auf in einer Million Jahren, aber trotzdem ist es einfach ziemlich strange und ich kann es einfach nicht verstehen. Das ist eines der Dinge, die ich nie verstehe, zum Beispiel Solarenergie. Glaub ich, werde ich auch nicht verstehen. Hör ich einfach auch direkt auf, mich darüber Gedanken zu machen. Aber das ist, glaube ich, noch so ein Ding, wo man sich da ein bisschen reinfuchst, dann geht das. Aber Magnete ist, glaube ich, so ein Ding wie Gott. Da ist so ein Gott in diesem Stein drin.
Ich glaube, direkt nach Gott kommt Magnete.
Ja, genau. Man weiss nicht mehr, viel danach kommt auch nicht mehr. Also danach ist erst mal lange nichts und dann kommt irgendwann so Photovoltaik und so. Da kann man sich reinfuchsen, das kann man sich anlesen, das wissen. Aber Magnete ist, glaube ich, so ein Ding, so Grenzwissenschaften. Ja, vor allem auch so Elektromagnete. Also zum Beispiel so ein alter Röhrenfernseher, ein alter Röhrenfernseher funktioniert ja dadurch, dass du irgendwelche Superteilchen hast, die da raufgeschossen werden und dann ist da so ein kleiner Magnet, der leitet die Teilchen dann ab auf den Punkt auf dem Bildschirm, wo man die haben will und das passiert unfassbar häufig, weil du für jeden Pixel pro Sekunde das einmal machen musst. Das heisst, du hast pro Sekunde 24 Bilder und wie viele Pixel hat ein Fernseher? Fünf Millionen, das heißt, du hast insgesamt über 100 Millionen dieser Dinger pro Sekunde. Der Magnet muss 100 Millionen mal pro Sekunde seine Richtung ändern. Das ist krass. Also stimmt natürlich nicht, das ist natürlich technisch kompletter Schwachsinn, das ist ja klar. Aber trotzdem ist die Vorstellung sehr beeindruckend, finde ich. Ich glaube, also Elektromagneten sind aber, die sind, das entzaubert das Ganze so ein bisschen, weil die sind ja, du steckst in eine Steckdose. War für mich auch tatsächlich ein Fehlschritt in der Entwicklung, hätte es für mich nicht gebraucht. Du steckst sie in eine Steckdose und dann geht halt etwas an, aber da ist ja klar, dass die Energie halt aus der Steckdose kommt. Und wenn du so ein Magnet hast, dann ist halt dieafel donnerst, dann ist halt die Steckdose nicht da und auch keine Energie, die du erstmal siehst. Das ist ja einfach das Faszinierende. Ich finde es gut, dass du dich auch so dafür begeistern kannst für das Thema Magnete. Naja, geht so. Ich glaube, meine Begeisterung ist ziemlich genau jetzt erschöpft. Also jetzt musst du mich übernehmen. Ne, da kommen noch super Geschichten, die ich mir ausgedacht habe, was man mit Magneten machen könnte. Ganz kurz, was war eigentlich am Wochenende los bei dir? Warum denn? Ich mache meinen Laptop auf, denke mir nichts, gehe auf Facebook, erwarte freudige Nachrichten, steht da ganz gross, riesengroße Schlagzeile, Stefan Titze likes Vox. Das verstehe ich auch nicht. Was ist da passiert? Was hast du mir gestern gesagt und ich wusste, ich wusste nicht, ich musste nachgucken, ich bin auf Vox gegangen, dann auf die Facebook-Seite und habe geguckt, ob ich wirklich mit denen irgendwie in Kontakt stehe und die wirklich geliked habe. Und ich habe es wirklich geliked und ich wusste es nicht bis jetzt. Und ich habe nie eine Facebook-Meldung auf der Timeline von denen gehabt. Also muss es irgendwie in so einem Schlafzustand, muss ich da irgendwie draufgekommen sein. Aber ich finde, das ist sowieso die Magie von Facebook, dass es gewisse Dinge gibt, die man eigentlich schon mag, wie zum Beispiel bei mir After-Aid, mag ich. Aber du würdest dich nicht trauen, die Seite zu liken. Aber trotzdem ist es ein sehr schwieriger Moment, wann man tatsächlich die Seite liked, weil es wirkt notwendigerweise willkürlich, wann man genau diese Seite liked. Und wenn ich After-Aid like, müsste ich eigentlich auch direkt Mars, Snickers, Twix und all das liken, was ich genauso gerne mag wie After-Aid. Aber ich würde es ja nicht machen, es ist trotzdem sehr willkürlich und dann kriegen alle meine Freunde die Message, Florentin Will likes After-Aid und jeder fragt sich, was steckt da dahinter? Das ist mir super suspekt. Was ist da passiert, dass er plötzlich jetzt seine Liebe zu After-Aid der ganzen Welt mitteilt? Ja, es sieht immer so aus, als ob jetzt irgendwie so eine Phase wäre. Und dann, wenn, ich hab so ein Gefühl, ja genau, ihm gefällt gerade jetzt, gefällt ihm irgendwas und er hat gerade jetzt seine Liebe zu Twix entdeckt oder so. Das ist, es wirkt so total so zeitabhängig, aber das ist ja gar nicht so. So eine Erleuchtung, ja. Es ist irgendwas, man hat da sofort so eine Legende im Kopf, wie irgendwas passiert, ein einschneidendes Erlebnis in seinem Leben und seitdem war nie irgendwas wieder vor, ab jetzt mag ich Twix. Man stellt sich vor, dass irgendwie so ein Twix-Superheld dich gerettet hat oder so, irgendwie so eine Geschichte, die spült sich dann im Gehirn ab. Das ist wie so, wie der Gag von Simpsons immer, wenn Bart was an die Tafel schreibt und man sich das vorstellt, wie das passiert ist, dass er jetzt irgendwie... Warum er diese Strafe hat, ja. Genau, dass er diese Strafe hat und was an die Tafel schreiben muss. Das ist, glaube ich, das gleiche System. Und deswegen ist Facebook auch wirklich ganz schön, es liegt alles offen und du kannst Leute damit manipulieren in deinem Umfeld, indem du, da weiß ich nicht, du kannst... Eigentlich müsste man mal einen Tag ausmachen, wo man sagt, jeder liked einfach alles, was er mag, damit wir das einfach mal vom Tisch haben, damit diese Likes auch wirklich einen gewissen Kommunikationswert haben, dass man sagt so, hey, ich habe Twix neu entdeckt, ich habe noch nie Twix gegessen und jetzt like ich es, dann ist eine Story da, aber ansonsten ist es einfach nur willkürlich. Ja, oder man verklickt sich halt, wie ich bei Vox, weil mir gefällt Vox nicht wirklich. Aber was hat dich dazu geleitet, Vox zu sein? Ich habe es aus Versehen gemacht, anscheinend. Das kann nicht sein. Ich habe es aus Versehen nicht draufgekommen. Man liked nicht aus Versehen. Es ist mir wirklich, ich weiß nicht, aus alten Zeiten vielleicht, nee, aber ich habe auch nie eine Nachricht von denen auf Teilen eingehalten. Also es muss wirklich relativ kurzfristig jetzt gewesen sein. Glaubst du, dass die 24 Leute, die das Podcast UFO geliked haben auf Facebook, das zufällig getan haben? Nein, da steckt Herzblut dahinter. Nee, beim Podcast UFO da steckt Herzblut dahinter. Wir sind schon so eine eingefleischte Community, wie man ja im Netz sagt. Das stimmt, ja. Wir halten zusammen, gehen durch dick und dünn, durch gute, schlechte Folgen. Und da steckt was dahinter, aber bei Vox glaube ich nicht. Und jetzt habe ich diese Folie auch wieder endliked. Ich weiß nicht, ob denen das jetzt so gefällt. Das ist hart. Vor allem wäre auch gut, wenn man das auch auf der Timeline angezeigt bekommen würde. Genau. Tietze gefällt Wox nicht mehr. Unliked Wox und man sich fragt, was ist da los, was ist passiert? Florentin Will gefällt Twix nicht mehr. Und alle fragen sich, was ist da passiert? Was ich mir letztens auch gedacht habe, also Weihnachten ist ja natürlich klar, steht ausser Frage. Wie muss man sich eigentlich in Florentinwil zur Weihnachtszeit vorstellen?
Ich bin sehr entspannt, allerdings auch sehr aufgeregt, weil ich muss heute tatsächlich noch ein Weihnachtsgeschenk einkaufen, deswegen starre ich eigentlich nur nervös auf die Uhr die ganze Zeit. Wann ist es endlich vorbei? Weil ich heute tatsächlich noch in die Stadt fahren muss, aber ich dachte mir, wir leben ja in der Kritikkultur, ja, sind wir mal ganz ehrlich. Heute wird alles kritisiert, egal was passiert, jeder Tweet, jedes Ereignis, jede Aussage von jedem Menschen in der Öffentlichkeit steht, zack, Kritik, keine Chance. Aber, wo ich mir mal dachte, warum werden gewisse Dinge nicht kritisiert, wie zum Beispiel Weihnachten, warum geht man da nicht mal mit der Lupe ran und sagt, ist das wirklich das bestmögliche Fest? Ein Konsum, ein Produkt der Konsumgesellschaft theoretisch. Aber das meine ich gar nicht. Stell dir mal vor, Weihnachten gäbe es erst nächstes Jahr. Wie die Leute sich die Mäuler zerreissen würden. Weihnachtsmann, ist das wirklich der beste Name? Ich meine, sehr unkreativ, dass zu Weihnachten der Weihnachtsmann kommt. Ist euch da nichts Besseres eingefallen? Das ist wirklich wahnsinnig unkreativ. Das fällt mir jetzt auf. Das ist extrem unkreativ. Das ist total scheiss. Auch Schneemann. Hallo, mein Gott, das sind drei Kugeln und die nennen den Schneemann. Ja, aber kann man da nicht mal eine vernünftige Kritikkultur etablieren, zu sagen, so geht's eigentlich nicht? Was habt ihr euch denn dabei gedacht? Würde in einem Film der Superheld Superman heißen, würde man auch sagen, habt ihr eigentlich einen Schaden? Denkt doch mal verdammt einen coolen Namen aus, nennt den irgendwie Gizmo oder Schmäcki
oder irgendwie sowas, aber nicht Superman.
Auch Spider-Man ist eigentlich auch wahnsinnig unkreativ.
Extrem unkreativ, kann man da nicht mal
rangehen. Ich meine, die Amerikaner haben Santa Claus,
ist für mich ein Schritt nach oben.
Ist für mich ein Eigenname, was
Gutes hat irgendwie Santa Claus, hat so zwei
Vierter. Naja, wir haben ja auch Nikolaus, wir haben ja auch den Nikolaus,
wo ich auch als Kind, und da hast du gemerkt,
das Fest, das hat sich irgendwie so auseinandergelebt, das hat sich weiterentwickelt, Jahre, Jahr über Jahr, und irgendwann gab es den Nikolaus, den Weihnachtsmann und das Christkind, und ich bin das Kind gar nicht mehr durchgestiegen an, was muss ich denn jetzt glauben? Genau, das ist wie so Superhelden-Prequels und Sequels, so Moment mal, was? Genau, und irgendwann gibt's auch Überschneidungen gewisse und man weiss nicht mehr, ist der Nikolaus und warum kommt der Onkel, der sich jetzt als Nikolaus verkleidet, als an Weihnachten?
Ist jetzt da irgendwie, hat er sich irgendwie, ist Nikolaus so ein Tag zum Anteasen oder was? Oder ist es der gleiche? Ist der Nikolaus der Weihnachtsmann? Ja, aber sind die überhaupt im gleichen Universum? Also so wie Superman und Spider-Man, glaube ich, sind ja diese unterschiedlichen Universen. Ist der Nikolaus und Weihnachtsmann, das sind ja unterschiedliche Universen. Eigentlich darf man ja gar nicht beide feiern. Nee, Nikolaus ist, glaub ich, ne sehr religiöse Figur und der Weihnachtsmann ist halt so eine Konsumfigur, sag ich jetzt mal. Und Christkind, aber Christkind ist auf einer Ebene mit Nikolaus. Ist auf einer Ebene mit Jesus, glaube ich. Also noch eine Stufe über Nikolaus. Aber zeitlich, zeitlich gesehen auch schwierig. Ich meine, Christkind, geboren im Jahre Null, Nikolaus, irgend so ein Papst im Jahre Vierzeundert, was auch immer. Nee, Nikolaus ist ein Türke. Ja gut, da möchte ich jetzt mal meine Meinung dazu vorgeschlossenen Mund halten. Aber eigentlich dürfte man da, eigentlich dürfte man, das ist eigentlich ein kompletter historischer Fehler. Ja. Das ist wie wenn du auf eine Kostümparty gehst und da ist Superman und Napoleon, da sagst du, Freunde, das funktioniert so nicht. Einer von euch beiden muss ich... Ganz kurz, kommt mal kurz zusammen, kommt mal kurz zusammen, das funktioniert nicht. Überlegt euch mal beide, was ihr falsch gemacht habt. Aber wusstest du, dass es so Reinkarnationspartys gibt? Es gibt ja Menschen, die daran glauben, dass sie reinkarniert wurden und im früheren Leben schon mal jemand anderes waren. Also das ist jetzt nicht so buddhistisch-religiös, sondern das sind einfach Vollidioten, irgendwelche Esoteriker und so ein Crap. Und dann gibt es da Reinkarnationspartys, wo sie dann hingehen als die Personen, die sie in ihrem früheren Leben schon mal waren. Und Surprise, Surprise! Die meisten gehen irgendwie als fiktionale Person, die sie gar nicht niemals gab. Oder halt extrem berühmte historische Person, da gibt es dann halt viermal Napoleon, wo die vier sich auch mal zu einem ernsten Gespräch zusammensetzen müssen und sagen, drei von uns lügen, wer, anders geht es nicht. Das ist ja grossartig, dann wäre es geil, wenn es so ein Duell gäbe, so wer ist der wahre Superman? Ja, vor allem auch wenn man wirklich an Reinkarnation glauben sollte, wie extrem unwahrscheinlich ist es denn, dass man gerade eine der berühmtesten historischen Personen der Welt war und nicht irgendein Soldat oder ein Bauer oder irgendwas. Nee, klar, aber das ist ja logisch, dass die Menschen dann direkt versuchen, sich irgendwie etwas Besonderes zu machen. Das finde ich schon logisch nachvollziehbar. Warum Leute das glauben? Es sind eh Vollidioten. Also auf so einer Vollidiot-Ebene ist es nachvollziehbar. Aber es ist sehr lustig, dieses Szenario, dass sich vier Napoleons gegenüberstehen, wahrscheinlich auch im gleichen Kostüm, weil sie sich irgendwie bei Amazon bestellt haben. Und dann sollte man wirklich so einen Test machen und sollte man auch mal Fragen stellen. Und ich glaube, die meisten von denen haben sich gar nicht richtig vorbereitet und wissen gar nicht, wann sie geboren wurden. Das stimmt, ja. Ich habe da mal auch so ein Buch gelesen über solche Rückführungen. Also so unter Hypnose hat man dann noch Sinneseindrücke von seinem früheren Leben. Und dann der Typ, der das Buch geschrieben hat, hat dann Leute befragt und ja, zu der und der Jahreszeit war ich irgendwie in Wien und dann gab es eine grosse Explosion und dann hat er das recherchiert und tatsächlich gab es in diesem Jahr eine grosse Explosion und das hätte der Patient überhaupt nicht wissen können und deswegen stimmt das alles und seitdem bin ich auch voll davon überzeugt. Das ist ja krass. Ich wollte mal kurz einen krassen Themenwechsel einschlagen. Hau rein, zieh die Handbremse an. Sterben, sterben. Also es ist ja so, dass jetzt, gestern ist Joe Cocker gestorben, davor ist Udi Jürgens gestorben. Die Frage ist, wer ist der Nächste?
Okay, okay.
Und deswegen haben wir doch mal irgendwann überlegt, als wir uns das Konzept uns überlegt haben. Schon lange her, schon lange her. Und dass irgendwann diesen Prozess aber zu früh abgebrochen haben, da haben wir doch darüber nachgedacht, Nachrufe zu schreiben über Leute, die noch leben, was ja auch ein gängiger Prozess ist, damit Leute und Zeitungen und so relativ früh Nachruf publizieren können. Oder auch damit man der Erste ist. Damit man der Erste ist, genau, und damit man auch relativ schnell ist. Das ist alles Schnelligkeit, das ist alles Clickbaiting, das ist alles sehr wichtig in der heutigen Zeit. Und deswegen haben wir mal überlegt irgendwann, dass wir Nachrufe schreiben über Leute, die noch leben, aber auch schon die Todesursache reinschreiben, weil damit wir dann quasi die exklusive Story haben. Es ist ein gewisses Risiko, aber ich glaube, es ist ein Risiko, das sich lohnt. Ich stelle mal vor, wir hätten bei Udo Jürgens die Herzattacke erraten und dann hätten wir es bei Twitter geschrieben, relativ früh, dann wären wir jetzt sowas wie die Ersten gewesen.
Aber ganz kurz, mir fällt da gerade eine Verschönungstheorie ein. War das nicht bei Steve Jobs so, dass fälschlicherweise jemand seinen Tod verkündet hat, irgendeine Zeitung und so einen Nachruf veröffentlicht hat? Und dann haben die ihn umgebracht, damit er warf. Aber warte mal, dann hiess es, ja stimmt gar nicht, der ist noch gar nicht tot, zwei Tage später war die Keynote und das neue iPhone wurde vorgestellt und ein paar Tage später ist er dann tatsächlich gestorben. Und die Vermutung ist, dass er wirklich schon davor gestorben ist, aber man seinen Tod verheimlicht hat, damit eben die Keynote nicht in einem schlechten Licht steht. Aber ich glaube, er hat sogar persönlich die Keynote moderiert, von daher glaube ich ... Moment, genau, sind Keynoten nicht immer live? Da glaube ich, ist die Verschwörungstheorie nicht haltbar. Oder es war jemand, der denkt, dass er mal Steve Jobs war und hat sich dann so verkleidet und hat sich dann auf die Bühne gestellt und es nachgemacht. Das sind für mich die schönsten Verschwörungstheorien, die mit einer kleinen Beobachtung sofort zerstört werden, aber sich trotzdem halten, auch in fünf Jahren. Das machen ja Verschwörungstheorien aus, die sind normalerweise alle mit einem Satz völlig zunichte zu machen. Also, wer stimmt? Vielleicht sollten wir das, ja, sollen wir das jetzt machen? Sollen wir jetzt Nachrufe schreiben oder sollen wir das noch für nächste Woche irgendwie, das war so eine Art Antieger. Es ist ein bisschen lame, wenn du das jetzt anteaserst. Die Leute können ja uns auch tolle Nachrufe selber schicken, wenn sie möchten.
Bei uns auch vielleicht.
Ich liebe es.
Wie sterben wir? Wie stirbt Florentin Will?
Ich hatte schon sehr viele unerfolgreiche Podcasts.
Und immer wieder habe ich gesagt, Leute, schickt uns dies und das ein, ohne es ist noch nie passiert.
Aber ich finde es super, dass du immer diese Begeisterung findest, um das nochmal zu fragen.
Meine tatsächliche Schätzung, wer als nächstes stirbt, Bill Cosby. Meinst du, der ganze Stress der letzten Monate, die ganze Kritik geht an so einem Mann nicht so vorbei? Ich glaube, da wird noch was passieren. Irgendwas passiert da noch. Autounfall? Vielleicht, vielleicht. Apropos Milka. Wir haben ja vorhin, glaube ich, irgendwann mal über Milka geschrieben und ich habe mir nur die Überleitung aufgeschrieben, apropos Milka. Ich habe so ein ganzes Überleitungsbuch, wo ich einfach apropos und dann verschiedene Worte dahinter geschrieben habe und da suche ich mir immer eine raus. Wir wollten ja auch über E-Mails sprechen. E-Mails sind ja so die Sache, mit der man sich täglich befestigt, beschäftigt und man kriegt ja... Wenn ich jetzt die ganze Zeit befestigt sage, dann sagst du auch, du bist doch so einer, der sich Versprecher einprägt. Das ist schön menschlich, das freut mich jetzt. So ein Geräusch zu hören, Florentin Will ist auch nur ein Mensch. Ich finde, Mails sind ja eine fantastische Kommunikationsform und tatsächlich die beste Kommunikationsform für mich. Ich liebe Mails, und endlich hat es die Technologie geschafft, eine Kommunikationsform hervorzubringen, die genau meiner sozialen Inkompetenz perfekt passt. Weil… Musst du erklären, warum reicht die SMS nicht? Also, da können wir ja gleich noch ein anderes heikles Thema anschneiden, und zwar die Häkchen bei WhatsApp. Dieses Gelesen nicht gelesen und so. Das ist ja,
das stand ja hart in der Kritik.
Und da wurde viel diskutiert,
auch im Sinne von, ja, awkward,
irgendwie man weiss, der andere hat sie schon gelesen,
er antwortet nicht, das ist ja auch schon eine
Kommunikation an sich, das ist ja eine Message, die
der andere ja eigentlich gar nicht senden möchte,
aber unweigerlich sendet, nimmt da das
Medium nicht schon die Kommunikation voraus
und nimmt dann nicht eigentlich schon die authentische Kommunikation was weg.
Und ich habe dazu eigentlich keine Meinung, aber ich frage mich, ob das irgendwann auch die E-Mail einholen wird, dass man dann auch sieht, wann der andere gelesen hat oder nicht oder ob das für immer und eben… Kann man schon. Es gibt schon diese so E-Mail, spezielle E-Mail-Programme, wo man eingeben kann, wie lange der andere die E-Mail lesen kann.
Also es kann auch sein, dass sie nach zehn Sekunden verschwindet. Das hat mich sehr geschockiert, dass es sowas gibt. Aber das liegt doch in der ... Beim anderen wird es doch gespeichert. Nee, nee, das ist so krass daran. Das ist ein Programm, da kannst du alles einstellen.
Du kannst einstellen, wann die gesendet werden soll, dass du eine Mail bekommst, wenn der andere die gelesen hat, dass sie sich selber zerstört quasi im gegnerischen Postfach. Das ist ganz schön, ganz so keiner Hackerscheiß. Aber du kannst doch keine Mail in den Postfachlöschen. Doch, das geht wirklich. Du, Florentin, es gibt ungeahnte Möglichkeiten. In einer Welt, wo es Magnete gibt, gibt es auch selbst verstörende E-Mails.
Ja, das glaube ich aber mal.
Nee, das ist wirklich ganz schön krass. Aber guck mal ganz ehrlich, bei Facebook ist das schon ultra lange, dass man sehen kann, wann der andere die Nachricht gelesen hat. Und deswegen habe ich auch diese Diskussion bei WhatsApp nicht verstanden. Warum plötzlich da alle sich aufregen drüber? Nee, ich find's auch eigentlich gar nicht, also ich find es eher hilfreich, weil es ist halt auch einfach oft so, dass man nicht weiß, ist der andere gerade gerade sein Handy dabei, hat der gerade Internet, ist der gerade überhaupt zu erreichen und das ist einfach extrem sinnvoll zu sehen, hat der andere das bekommen. Und man sieht mal schwarz auch weiss, dass der andere nichts mit dir zu tun haben will. Ja, absolut, aber das finde ich auch in Ordnung. Also ich meine, ich finde,ert ja eine Kultur der Ehrlichkeit, zu sagen, man hat einfach nicht immer Bock, direkt zu antworten und kann das auch nicht direkt vortäuschen. Aber finde ich auch okay. Bist du denn jemand, der Fake-Anrufe benutzt? Also wenn er aus einer unangenehmen Situation rauskommen möchte, sich anrufen lässt? Ja, aber meistens verstecke ich das dann und tue ich immer so etwas, als es vibriert. Und dann werde ich aber genau in dem Moment angerufen, wenn ich das Handy am Hohe habe. Ja, Classic, ja. Ja, aber meistens verstecke ich das dann und tue ich immer so, dass das vibriert und dann werde ich aber genau in dem Moment angerufen, wenn ich das Handy am hohen habe. Ja, Classic, ja.
Ja, Classic und das ist wirklich so, das würde mir auch wirklich passieren. Es gibt da so ein Startup und zwar haben die so einen Knopf erstellt, das ist einfach so ein kleines Plastikding mit einem Knopf. Und dem kann man ganz viele Funktionen zuweisen, also das kann dann mit seinem Smartphone verbinden und meinetwegen dann einstellen, wenn ich auf den Knopf drücke, wird die und die Pizza bestellt, automatisch. Und dann hast du halt diesen Knopf und dann drückst du da drauf, ohne dass du auf deinem Smartphone das irgendwie manuell einstellen musst. Und dann haben die so ein Video gemacht, um das darzustellen, was man damit alles machen kann. Und ein Beispiel war, man kann auf dem Knopf programmieren, dass man einen Fake-Anruf bekommen möchte und hat den dann irgendwie bei einem Date oder so, so ganz Geheimagentenmässig so in der Innentasche von seinem Anzug und kann dann da so draufdrücken und wird dann angerufen. Fand ich eigentlich ganz geil, aber wo ich mir dachte, wenn das eines der Beispiele ist, wie du dein Produkt vermarktest, von welcher Menschheit gehst du eigentlich aus? Ist das nicht ein Armutszeugnis? Ja. Nö, nö, nö, wie gesagt, das war so ein Ehrlichkeitsding und irgendwie, man merkt ja auch, wenn der andere einen verarscht, weil er gerade einen Knopf gedrückt hat, offensichtlich, nachdem er fünf Minuten gekramt hat in der Tasche und dann sich anrufen lässt von diesem Knopf und dann, das ist auch wieder so ein Ehrlichkeitsding, also da zeigst du einem indirekt auch, dass du nichts mehr zu tun haben. Eigentlich hätte dieser Knopf überhaupt keine Funktion nötig, sondern man drückt ihn einfach als Zeichen, ich habe keinen Bock mehr, mit dir Zeit zu verbringen und geht. Eigentlich muss er gar keine Funktion haben. Man hält ihn so unter die Nase des anderen, drückt drauf. So, wir wollen dann zahlen. Fände ich eigentlich auch ganz geil, weil man spricht es immer noch nicht direkt aus, was ja das Schlimme ist. Aber es hat so einen Symbolcharakter, der es einem erleichtert, einem anderen zu sagen, leck mich und hau einfach ab und halt einfach die Fassel. Also ich finde, das ist ja sehr wichtig. Es ist ja für die menschliche Psyche oder das menschliche Bewusstsein extrem, es ist ein großer Unterschied, ob etwas direkt oder indirekt ausgesagt wird. Zum Beispiel Mails. Bei Mails sagt man, tobt man sich eher, sich irgendwo hinzuschreiben, als direkt anzurufen. Ja, aber ich rede jetzt eher so von sozialen Codes. Also zum Beispiel, du hast eine Freundin, also keine Freundin, sondern eine Freundin von dir, mit der du dich gut verstehst, und du möchtest die Freundschaft aufs nächste Level bringen. So, und dann trefft ihr euch irgendwann und dann steht ihr vor ihrer Tür und dann fragt sie dich, willst du noch für einen Kaffee hochkommen? Ja, also Code für, willst du mit mir schlafen? Ja, sehr aufsichtig. Und dann versteht sie, versteht er, und er hat aber dann trotzdem die Möglichkeit, Nein zu sagen, ohne ... Indem er den Knopf rausholt. Indem er den Knopf rausholt, ohne dass es unangenehm wird. Weil, obwohl beide wissen, was sie gemeint hat, können sie ab jetzt trotzdem noch so tun, als wäre es wirklich nur um Kaffee gegangen, und sie können ihre Freundschaft normal weiterführen. Als wenn sie gesagt hätte, willst du mit mir schlafen, der exakt selbe Inhalt, und er sagt nein, könnten Sie die Freundschaft nicht so fortführen, weil es immer im Raum stehen wird.
Naja, aber sie kann ja auch sagen, willst du noch auf einen Kaffee rauskommen und er kann sagen, nee, ich mag keinen Kaffee. Dann führst du die gleiche Diskussion, nur halt auf einer Metaebene.
Absolut, aber...
Das macht es ja aber nicht besser.
Naja, es macht es schon besser.
Man kodiert das ja sofort wieder, er dekodiert das in seinem Körper sofort.
Ja, aber trotzdem, du kannst so tun, als wäre es nie ausgesprochen worden. Und das kannst du nicht, wenn es tatsächlich gesagt wurde. Das ist ein grosser Unterschied. Das ist ein grosser Unterschied. Meinst du wirklich? Es ist ein riesiger Unterschied, natürlich. Es ist ein riesiger Unterschied, ob das ausgesprochen wurde für einen gedachten Beobachter, einen gedachten anderen, für sozusagen das ideologische Weltverständnis. Es ist extrem wichtig, ob Dinge direkt ausgesprochen werden oder kodiert, obwohl der Code eigentlich keiner ist, obwohl den Code jeder versteht. Es ist extrem wichtig. Das ist eine steile These. Es war zum Beispiel auch so, da interessiert mich ja sehr Sowjetunion, so, da war es so, da hatte jeder gute sowjetische Bürger, hatte ein Lexikon, so das grosse kommunistische Lexik, bla bla blub. Da standen dann alle Führer drin und alle Politiker und so. Und irgendeiner dieser Politiker wurde dann als Verräter gekennzeichnet und wurde, glaube ich, hingerichtet oder entlassen oder so auf jeden Fall. Und dann hat die Redaktion von diesem Lexikon an jeden Besitzer von diesem Lexikon eine neue Seite für ihr Lexikon geschickt und hat sie dazu aufgefordert, schneidet die Seite raus, auf der dieser Politiker steht, und klebt die neue Seite rein. So, da fragt man sich ja auch, für wen machen die das denn? Weil jeder, der dieses Lexikon hat, weiß ja, dass es gefälscht ist, weil er es ja selber gefälscht hat. Am Ende ist ja niemandem geholfen, aber es ist trotzdem wichtig, was in diesem Lexikon steht, als ideologisches Fremderbetrachter, wo eben diese Ideologie festgehalten wird. Es ist trotzdem wichtig, was da drin steht, weil ein gedachter Beobachter das sozusagen so wahrnimmt. Es ist eben ein Unterschied, ob jemand das wirklich direkt sagt oder ob es kodiert ist. Und genau so ist es dasselbe, weil du musst immer den Schein aufrechterhalten können. Du kannst immer noch sagen, ja, aber eigentlich steht es ja so im Lexikon, eigentlich ist die Welt ja so, obwohl du ganz genau weißt, dass es anders ist. Und so ist es in der Beziehung mit dem Kaffeetrinken genauso. Obwohl beide es wissen, ist es ein extremer Unterschied, ob es tatsächlich so ausgesprochen wurde, beziehungsweise wie es im Lexikon steht. Ich trinke halt Kaffee übrigens. Das hat das Gespräch auch bei mir Bock auf Kaffee gemacht. Ich weiß nicht warum, ob das irgendwie... Ich trinke ja keinen Kaffee. Mal was anderes, die Mails, ne? Ist es bei dir auch so, dass du lieber Mail schreibst, als anrufst? Total gerne, ja. Da habe ich richtig verstanden. Absolut.
Und warum ist das wohl so?
Weil ich meine, SMS schreiben ist wieder irgendwie so eine intimere Nummer.
Wenn du SMS schreibst, dann musst du, naja, aber es ist schon eher so ein, man kennt sich ein bisschen länger, hat schon die Handynummern ausgetauscht und schreibt SMS.
Und Mails ist eher etwas Unpersönlicheres.
Du musst auch immer wieder Hallo schreiben und hast dann ein bisschen mehr Platz. Also du kannst schreiben, was du willst, aber du hast halt, du mails in der Gemeinde etwas länger. Das ist tatsächlich eine gute Frage, ab wann man die Begrüssung wiederholt, aber da können wir gleich drauf eingehen. Aber ich finde, Mail ist halt auch deswegen sehr gut, weil es eine grössmögliche Kontrolle dir eigentlich gibt, weil man auch immer sagen kann, ja, ich habe viel zu tun. Die Mail hat, finde ich, immer noch so diesen Status des nicht ständig Erreichbaren, wohingegen eine SMS ist ja auf ein mobiles Gerät zugeschnitten, da kann man immer davon rechnen, dass der andere die Nachricht sofort bekommt, bei Mail aber nicht. Da gibt es so Sachen wie, ich bin jetzt über die Feiertage nicht erreichbar, sowas würde man bei einer SMS nie schreiben, man würde niemals einen Algorithmus entwerfen, der, wenn man eine SMS bekommt, automatisch zurückschreibt, ich bin die Feiertage nicht da, weil es schon eher etwas Förmliches hat, um die Werte zu schreiben.
Ich habe gestern eine Kollegin bei uns aus der Firma, die hat gestern so eine Out-of-Office eingestellt, also so eine Abbildungsanz. Habe ich auch bekommen, ja.
Ja, aber ohne dass man was schreibt.
Ultra geil.
Genau, man hat nichts geschrieben, ich habe von allen Mails, die ich ihr jemals geschickt habe, die waren schon von vor drei Monaten, und das ist sozusagen meine Chefin, und ich schreibe richtig, richtig viele Mails, und die schreibt mir auch, ich bin immer in CC bei irgendeinem Scheiß, und sie ist bei mir auch immer in CC, und ich habe Millionen Mails ihr geschrieben, und ich habe von jeder Kack-Mail gestern in Out of Office bekommen, dass sie jetzt irgendwie im Urlaub bis zum 5. Januar ist, wo ich mir auch denke, es ist mir scheißegal, aber ich will jetzt einfach keine Out-of-Office bekommen, du warst dann nicht im Urlaub. Dann habe ich ihr geschrieben, so ein bisschen angenärbt schon, was da los ist bei ihr, dann meinte sie, ja, sie hat das falsch eingestellt und jetzt hat sie die Serververbindung gekappt. Das war echt, das war echt krass. Das war, hast du auch bekommen? Ja, vor allem, ich frage mich, also diese, diese vorauseilende Mail, ne, also ohne dass sie selber eine Mail bekommen hat, um dann zu sagen, ich kann nicht auf deine Mail reagieren, schreibt sie schon vorweg, ich werde ab jetzt nicht auf ihre Mails reagieren können, was zwar eigentlich schon sinnvoll ist, aber irgendwie schon so ein, äh, hallo, warum denkst du denn, dass ich was mit dir zu tun haben will, äh, hallo, so will ich dich bis so auch nicht. Ich nehme an, dass du in den nächsten Monaten mit mir schreiben willst, aber ich bin nicht da. Ich will dir jetzt schon sagen, ich kann dir nicht zuhören. Aber das heisst ja, was sie einstellen konnte, dass man rückwirkend eine Out-of-Office einstellt. Und das ist doch eine ganz komische Funktion, die man da offensichtlich anklicken kann. Das macht ja gar keinen Sinn. Das ist aber eigentlich ein geiler Move. Also wenn du auf einer Party bist, gehst du zu jemandem hin und sagst, hey Leute, ich kann die nächsten zehn Minuten nicht mit euch reden, ne, macht's gut und gehst wieder. Das ist eigentlich ein ganz schöner Move, gefällt mir ganz gut. Ich finde auch, genau, so Mails in die Wirklichkeit zu transportieren, ist auch gut. Ich glaube, das könnte eine gute Sketch-Serie werden. Das soll man mal mit Tele 5 besprechen. Immer, das ist so, als wenn ich dich in jedem Satz neu begrüsse.
Ja, hallo, mir geht's gut.
Tele5, wenn du gerade zuhörst, hier schlummert eine Monster-Comedy-Formatnummer, das wird was.
Ohne Scheiss, Tele5 ist glaube ich ein Pflaster, worauf wir setzen sollten.
Wir sollten jetzt so kleine Sämchen pflanzen im Boden und dann sollten da irgendwann auf Tele5 es fruchtbar rbar. Willst du wirklich Vox vergrätzen? Ich dachte, du magst Vox. Nee, gefällt mir nicht mehr. Aber das ist tatsächlich... Seit gestern gefällt es nicht mehr. Also bei Mails ist tatsächlich die Frage, wann man die Begrüssung wiederholt. Also zum Beispiel, nehmen wir doch mal besagte Chefin einfach. Bist du der Erste in der Konversation, der jeweils aufhört zu begrüssen oder wartest du, bis der andere aufhört zu begrüssen oder machst du das von einem Standpunkt aus? Es kommt natürlich auch ein bisschen darauf an, wie man verabschiedet wird. Also wenn man sagt, hier lieber, bla bla bla und dann der andere antwortet dann nur noch mit du und verabschiedet dann, liebe Grüße Paul, dann schreibe ich nur noch Hey Paul und dann schreibt er irgendwas und dann gar nichts mehr. Es ist so ein schleichender Abstieg von Begrüßungsformeln. Also am Anfang sehr geehrte Damen und Herren, dann lieber Paul, dann jo was geht, dann fick dich du Arschloch und dann gar nichts mehr. Ich habe irgendwann mal so eingeführt, je kürzer die Mail, umso weniger Begrüßung. Also wenn die Mail sehr kurz ist, schreibe ich nur noch irgendwie Hey, wenn die Mail relativ lang ist, schreibe ich sehr geehrte, meistens ist es so. Das kann man relativ gut abhängig machen, mache ich aber seitdem nicht mehr, als ich mal eine Kollegin auch bei uns in der Firma irgendwie angeschrieben habe und dann war die Mail irgendwie sehr kurz, war eine ganz kurze Frage, da habe ich die Begrüßung einfach komplett weggelassen und es kam zurück als Antwort, ja das heißt Hallo oder eine Mail beginnt man mit Hallo. Das ist aber auch hart, würdest du das wirklich machen? Nee, nein, also meinst du von dir aus sehen? Das fand ich auch relativ hart, aber seitdem mache ich immer eine Begrüßung. Egal wie kurz die Mail ist, schreibe ich immer zumindest irgendwie Hallo oder so. Also ich finde Höflichkeit einfordern sowieso suspekt, weil das so ein bisschen die Idee von Höflichkeit eigentlich unterbaut. Das ist genauso, wenn man Höflich Schenk einfordern würde, das ruiniert komplett den Sinn eines Geschenks, dass man sie nämlich freiwillig und gerne mit Liebe gibt.
Ich finde, du hast heute richtig gute Ansichten.
Dankeschön.
Und du kannst auch alles begründen heute. Du bist in so einer, wir sind in so einer seriösen Stimmung heute, aber wir begründen, beziehungsweise mit wir meine ich dich, du begründest wahnsinnig gut heute und hast gute Ansichten und du scheinst so sehr besonnen heute zu sein.
Ich bin im weihnachtlichen Entspannungsmodus zu. Ich bin gerade aufgewacht, muss ich auch mal sagen.
Ganz kurz, also du sagst, je länger die Mail, desto förmlicher die Begrüßung. Was ist denn das Maximum?
Was ist denn die höchstmögliche Begrüßung, die möglich ist?
Also sehr geehrt ist schon, finde ich immer zu krass, finde ich eigentlich immer zu krass, auch wenn man die Leute nicht kennt.
Sehr geehrte Damen und Herren und ein freundliches Hallo auch von mir. Und meinen Kollegen. Aber vor allem, ich habe da immer Angst, dass es ins Ironische umschlägt, dass wenn die Begrüßung zu förmlich ist, dass es dann umschlägt in der will mich verarren. Ich finde, ich finde sehr geehrte immer schon sehr, sehr ironisch. Also ich, wenn ich schreibe, meine ich immer ironisch, weil ich niemals, stell mir vor, du würdest zu jemandem gehen und sagen, sehr geehrt, das ist noch so, das kommt aus dem Mittelalter gefühlt. Mail kommt ja aus dem Mittelalter, die Mail-Tradition. Das Wort Mail kommt ja wie Jane Mail, Kettenhemd, hat ja was damit zu tun. Genau, und das ist auch so, man würde niemals im Leben zu jemandem gehen und sagen, sehr geehrte Frau Paulsen, ich würde dann gerne jetzt Pause machen oder so.
Würdest du niemals machen?
Das ist wirklich so ein Ding, was irgendwie übernommen wurde und dann auch irgendwie nicht mehr überdacht wurde.
Man sollte einfach Hallo bei Hallo bleiben.
Wie sieht es denn eigentlich bei dir aus mit Signaturen?
Habe ich. Habe ich eine von einer Firma aus, weil es halt so macht.
Also weil es alle haben und weil es irgendwie auch, glaube ich, Pflicht ist sogar. Weiß ich nicht genau. Und was sagst du zum Thema Verabschiedungen? Das war alles, was du zum Thema Signaturen wissen wolltest? Ja, also ich wollte dir jetzt nur die Möglichkeit geben, deine knallige Anekdote rauszuhauen, aber wenn da nichts kommt, was soll ich denn machen? Es kommt gar nicht von mir heute. Nein, ich habe keine Signatur und ich weiß nicht, ich finde Signaturen auch immer ein bisschen, also wenn ich eine Mail von jemandem bekomme, den ich persönlich kenne und da steht dann drunter irgendwie Gustav Schleicher, Fotograf, Designer, Architekt, Nummer, Nummer, Büro und ich mir, was will der denn eigentlich? Bei manchen steht in der Signatur ja auch eine Verabschiedung drin. Oh, ganz ruhig. Das finde ich immer super scheiße. Oh, da müssen wir gleich noch über Verabschiedungen, weil da... Und dann Leute, die Verabschiedungen schreiben, und darunter noch eine Verabschiedung machen. Das ist dann die doppelte Negation, und dann meint er das gar nicht ernst und so. Oder er meint es doppelt ernst. Er sagt, alle anderen kriegen nur die Signaturverabschiedung, für dich aber habe ich noch mal eine extra Verabschiedung geschrieben. Wie verabschiedest du dich denn? Ich kann dir mal eine Mail von dir raussuchen. Das ist interessant. Das ist jetzt ein bisschen fies auch so, hinter dem Rücken eine Mail einfach raussuchen. Warte mal, schreiben wir uns viele Mails? Nein, wir schreiben uns nie Mails eigentlich. Chapeau, ich hasse unsere Internetseite, ich habe aus Versehen Dinge gelöscht, sorry, aber weder eine Begrüssung noch eine Verabschiedung, nichts. Nee, du bist auch nicht so der Typ, den ich begrüßen würde, Auch auf der Strasse nicht. Ich will einfach direkt in Medias reden. Mail davor, ups, Ausrufezeichen. Hey Kai, ist heute Abend das Tonstudio frei? Meinst du, Florentin und ich könnten privat was aufnehmen, so ein Stündchen, ginge das später, LG, Ausrufezeichen. Aha, wir haben eine Verabschiedung, grosses L, grosses G, Ausrufezeichen. Nicht schlecht, erkläre dich. LG ist für mich, also LG und Liebe Grüße trenne ich strikt, das ist nicht das gleiche. LG ist wesentlich persönlicher und so ein bisschen legerer, es wirkt so ein bisschen by the way mässiger. Und Liebe Grüße ausgeschrieben ist schon mit einem Ausrufezeichen dahinter, ist auf jeden Fall ironisch gemeint. Und LG, also nur als Abkürzung mit dem Ausrufezeichen, ist irgendwie so ein bisschen freundschaftlich.
Ich sehe, du hast ja hier die Verabschiedungen des Kommunikationspartners übernommen.
Er hat auch LG geschrieben und du zurück LG Ausrufezeichen.
Das ist was, was aber auch im echten Leben so ist.
Achtung mal drauf, wenn die Leute begrüsst, begrüssen die dich meistens mit dem Wort zurück.
Wenn ich mal abends irgendwo hingehe und sage Moin, was ja offensichtlich irgendwie blöd ist, weil es nicht morgen ist, dann antworten die auch meistens mit Moin zurück, obwohl sie es sonst niemals machen würden. Die würden dich niemals mit Moin begrüssen. Wenn du sagst Hallo, dann begrüße ich dich mit Hallo zurück. Achte mal drauf. Leute begrüssen meistens so zurück, wie sie begrüßt werden. Leute haben keine eigene Meinung, Menschen haben keine eigene Meinung. Doch, ist wirklich so. Und ich habe eingestellt bei mir, dass wenn ich Gross L, gross G eingebe oder klein l, klein g glaube ich auch, dann vervollständigt der daraus, macht liebe Grüße daraus. Und bei ihm habe ich das anscheinend sogar weggemacht, das ausgeschriebene Liebegrüße und habe ein L, G hingemacht, damit es freundschaftlicher wirkt. Also man denkt offensichtlich sehr viel dabei nach, wenn man Mail schreibt. Aber das ist tatsächlich echt so. Ich finde, Mail schreiben sind echt eine Kunst. Und ich muss sagen, ich habe in meiner Karriere schon einige sehr schöne Mails geschrieben. Aber auch schon sehr viel schlechte. Aber auch schon sehr viel schlechte. Vor allem manchmal, wenn ich so gewisse Dinge rüberbringen will, überlege ich mir das schon im Vorhinein irgendwie. So einen Tag davor überlege ich mir schon Formulierungen, wie man das gut um... Weil ich habe tatsächlich, ich bin so ein bisschen paranoid... Für welche Mails das denn? Ja, ich bin so ein bisschen... Das müssen aber schon sehr wichtige Mails. Ja, ich bin so ein bisschen paranoid, dass man mich falsch verstehen könnte, weil ich mache sehr oft die Erfahrung, dass Menschen mich komplett falsch verstehen. Also entweder, wenn ich zu viel schreibe, denken die Leute, es ist ironisch, wenn ich zu wenig schreibe, denken die Leute, es ist unhöflich. Wenn ich einfach nur die Information rüber bringe, hey, wollen wir uns um zwölf treffen, ich bin dann da, ich nehme die S-Bahn, ciao. So, wenn ich sowas schreibe, kommt es sehr oft so
Was ist mit dir los, geht's dir nicht gut?
Und ich so, nein, überhaupt nicht, ich wollte einfach nur Informationen
rüberbringen. Die wollen Smilies, die Leute
brauchen Smilies, du bist auch ein Mensch, der keine Smilies
macht und das macht alles kaputt.
Die Smilies, die sind ja nicht ohne Grund
erfunden worden von, von,
weiß ich nicht wem. Sony.
Steve, Sony. Aber ich mag einfach
keine Smilies, ich finde, das ist überflüssig. Ich finde, das ist eine Armutserklärung. Nein, das ist gar nicht. Ich finde, es muss auch ohne gehen. Ich finde, das ist einfach schwachsinnig, wenn man dadurch alles versucht zu relativieren. Ab und zu. Moment, Moment, Moment. Haben eigentlich früher, haben Nietzsche und so, die haben ja auch viele Briefe geschrieben. Und die gibt es ja auch noch. Haben die Smileys gemacht oder so? Die haben, glaube ich, auch Smileys, aber die hatten dann alle so einen Bart. Die hatten dann dann alle so einen ganz auslagenden Bart. Semikodon, Semikodon, Klammer zu oder so? Geschwung in eine Klammer auf, ja. Haben die sowas? Und dann haben die sich auch schon im Schnauzer gemacht und so lange Perücken, so Weisshaarperücken. Genau, ja. Auch ein guter Sketch. Ich glaube, Tele5, da laufen gerade die Hotlines heiß. Tele5 schreibt so mit, die haben einen Praktikantendrang gesetzt, der die Sendung irgendwie protokolliert.
Protokolliert und alle Gags müssen blau markiert werden.
Aber es ist nicht so viel heute.
Aber es ist egal. Ich finde auch immer eine ernstere Sendung.
Ich habe mir überlegt, was waren denn so die wichtigsten Mails,
die ich jemals geschrieben habe.
Da sind mir zwei eingefallen. Und einmal habe ich
geschrieben an den Milka-Kundensupport.
Habe ich geschrieben. Das ist schon eine ganze
Weile her. Leider habe ich die Mail nicht mehr.
Apropos Milka.
Ich habe sie tatsächlich, aber ich habe sie nicht mitgenommen. Ich habe sie auf meinem anderen Rechner, leider. Was ist die erste Mail, die du geschrieben hast? Test. Nimm mal deinen Mail-Provider und schreib mal ganz runter. Das ist, glaube ich, sehr schön, gefällt mir sehr gut. Sehr, sehr gute Idee, Stefan Tietze. Und zwar war das der zweite, dritte 2013 2013, und zwar habe ich geschrieben Test. Ach nein! Doch ich habe von einer anderen Mail an meine Mail Test geschrieben. Ich habe, das hat gar keinen Sinn, was ich gemacht habe. Ich glaube, es löscht sich irgendwann auch, ne? Ja, auf jeden Fall. Ich war offensichtlich mittendrin in irgendeinem Gespräch. Naja, das ist nicht cool. Da habe ich noch gearbeitet bei der Zeitung. Oh, der feine Herr. Da habe ich geschrieben, Stefan Tietze, meine Adresse, mein Geburtsdatum und dass ich ein Praktikum mache. Aber auch nur mit Hallo und Danke und mit freundlichen Grüßen beendet. Ich mache auch immer so Danke, egal, auch wenn ich mich nicht zu bedanken habe, einfach um mich unterzuwerfen dem anderen. Und dann danke und mit freundlichen Grüßen Stefan mal meistens. Ach, danke auch nochmal? Was ich ja tatsächlich... Danke im Voraus ist mein Catchphrase bei Mails. Danke im Voraus. Was hältst du denn von sowas wie, würde mich über eine Antwort freuen? Absolut scheiße. Ja, erkläre. Weil du machst dem anderen ein schlechtes Gewissen.
Der muss dann antworten, weil sonst hat er ein schlechtes Gewissen.
Das ist wirklich scheisse. Ja, vor allem es ist ja auch...
Das ist richtig kacke.
Ich hasse sowas, sollte ich das machen.
Man betont ja offensichtliches. Wenn du Dinge fragst oder eine Mail schreibst, die eine Antwort erfordert, musst du nicht erwähnen, weil das ist der Sinn der Mail.
Das ist genauso, als wenn du einfach bei der Mail drunter schreibst, ich würde mich über Geschenke freuen, auch wenn es um etwas ganz anderes geht.
Ja, aber das ist der Sinn der Mail. Das ist genauso, als wenn du einfach bei der Mail drunter schreibst, ich würde mich über Geschenke freuen, wenn es um etwas ganz anderes geht. Ja, aber das ist das Gleiche. Du implizierst, du willst, du sagst einfach andeutig, dass du offensichtlich in einer schlechteren Position bist, in einer schlechteren Verhandlungsposition bist und dich über eine Antwort freuen musst, obwohl es die andere wahrscheinlich gar nicht nötig hat. Das sprichst du aus. Das ist im Sinne von, man muss ihm noch mal sagen, dass er eine Antwort schreibt, weil alleine kommt er nicht drauf.
Und bei mir reagiere ich da oft mit Trotzreaktionen, dass ich da sage, nee, dann kriegt er keine Antwort oder eine Antwort auf dem anderen Weg. Und das antwortest du nicht. Ich antworte ihm über Facebook oder ich schreibe ihm Brief, nur allein um da nicht darauf einzugehen, weil dann hat er recht. Das ist genau so dieses Mutterproblem. Ich weiß nicht, ob du dieses klassische Mutterproblem kennst, aus dem man nicht rauskommt. Und zwar, keine Ahnung, also ich gehe jetzt mal wirklich auf Kindheit zurück. Meinetwegen, du hast mit deiner Mutter vereinbart, dass du jeden Sonntag dein Zimmer aufräumst. So, und jetzt kommt deine Mutter am Sonntagmorgen zu dir ins Zimmer und sagt, denk dran, du musst heute noch dein Zimmer aufräumen. Und du denkst dir immer, ich hätte es auch gemacht, wenn du mir es nicht gesagt hättest, weil wir haben ja vereinbart, jeden Sonntag räume ich mein Zimmer auf. Dann räumst du dein Zimmer auf, dann kommt deine Mutter rein, aha, ja, muss ich es dir aber nochmal sagen. Wo du genau sagst, nein, aber man kann nichts dagegen tun, weil sie es immer schon sagt, bevor man überhaupt reagieren kann. Und wenn du schreibst, ich würde mich bei der Antwort freuen, und es kommt eine Antwort, ist die Antwort weniger wert, weil du ja geschrieben hast, ich würde mich bei der Antwort freuen. Und dann denkst du dir, oh nein, hat er das nur geantwortet, weil ich das geschrieben habe. Du machst dich ja selber kaputt. Ja, und der andere denkt so, oh gut, dass ich es geschrieben habe, dass er antworten soll, weil er hat ja geantwortet, damit hat er recht. Aber dass du so oder so geantwortet hättest, kannst du gar nicht darstellen, weil es diese Dimension nicht mehr gibt. Das ist furchtbar. Mails sind scheiße. Das ist echt, aber das würde ich gerne als das Mutterproblem in den öffentlichen Sprachgebrauch aufnehmen. Das Mutterproblem? Ja. Das ist sehr gut, das Zimmeraufräumenproblem. Ne, das ist nicht so catchy. Das ist furchtbar. Sehr gut. Du bist halt wirklich gut drauf, muss man sagen. Dankeschön, dankeschön. Vielen Dank. Aber mehr habe ich auch nicht.
Hat sich das Thema erschöpft eigentlich?
Ich glaube, Mails ist auch so ein Thema,
was man durchaus über zehn Sendungen zu tun könnte. Was ich oft bemerkt habe, Ironie funktioniert nicht.
In Mails?
Doch, mit Zwinker-Smileys.
Ja.
Ich habe gerade eine Mail von meiner Mutter, sehe ich gerade.
Und wie verabschiedet sich gerade der Mutter, wenn sie dir schreibt?
Schreibt sie dir, weiss ich nicht, mit freundlichen Grüßen, Mutter?
Vielen Dank. Ja. Ich habe gerade eine Mail von meiner Mutter, sehe ich gerade. Und wie verabschiedet sich da deine Mutter, wenn sie dir schreibt? Schreibt sie dir, weiss ich nicht, mit freundlichen Grüßen, Mutter. Mutter. Bei mir steht LG, grossgeschrieben, M. Also LG, M. Sie meinen mit M Mama wahrscheinlich. LG. LG, liebe Grüße und dann M. Wie die von James Bond. Zum Beispiel habe ich, als ich über die Weihnachten an meine beiden Eltern geschickt habe, also Mutter und Vater, Ach so, eine Weihnachtsrate geschickt, eine Weihnachtsgift? Nein, da habe ich geschrieben, liebe Erzeuger, habe ich geschrieben als Anschluss, wo ich mir dachte, ein kleiner Gag, ein bisschen die Stimmung aufbrechen, man kann ja auch mit seinen Eltern mal ein bisschen lustig, schreibt meine Mutter zurück, Antwort, LG Mama, die dich und an ihren Grossbuchstaben geboren hat, nicht erzeugt. Wo ich mir dachte. Oh Gott, hätte es mir lieber gelassen. So unangenehm, weil, denkt meine Mutter wirklich, ich würde nicht verstehen, wie Kinder gemacht werden, dass eine Frau, aber ich habe ja an beide geschrieben, also Mutter und Vater als gemeinsame Gruppe der Erzeuger zu benennen, finde ich das jetzt auch nicht falsch. Nee, ist doch so ein kleiner Classy-Gag. Aber sie hat es überhaupt nicht verstanden und wollte mich tatsächlich in der menschlichen Anatomie korrigieren und sagen, ich habe dich geboren nicht erzeugt. Das ist mir schon ... Also ganz unangenehm. Mama! Also sowas lieber einfach mal lassen. Also einfach, manchmal ist es auch besser, einfach straight nur Informationen zu liefern und das gar nicht zu versuchen, lustig zu sein oder irgendwie dann einen spaßigen Ton reinzubringen. Das klappt nicht. Nee, das ist manchmal echt nicht so sinnvoll, bei Mails echt nicht. Aber ich habe auch damals, als ich mich bei der BTF beworben habe zum Beispiel, da habe ich auch, das ist die Firma, wo ich arbeite, um mal für die Zuschauer, die wir ins Boot zu holen, da habe ich auch versucht, lustig zu sein in der Mail. Ich dachte, das ist ein lustiger Verein, die sind alle super lustig und dann habe ich mir die Mail nochmal durchgelesen, vor so ein paar Monaten und dachte mir echt, oh weia, da kannst du froh sein, dass du genommen wurdest bei diesem Scheißton. Kannst du die nochmal raussuchen? Das würde mich jetzt echt interessieren. Aber die finde ich echt nicht mehr. Also die ist mit Sicherheit auch gar nicht
mehr ... Das löscht sich irgendwann mal in den Mails. Nee, das war so ein Ton so, ja, ich habe gerade
angefangen in Köln zu studieren und da es ausser hier Bauersucht Frau und sowas gar nichts anderes
gibt. Mit so einem lakonischen Scherzton, der mir überhaupt nicht ankommt. Das war ganz schön scheiße eigentlich. Stichwort Betreff. Stichwort Magneten. Betreff ist für mich oft so ein Feld, das eigentlich mehr Fragezeichen hervorruft, als es... Das ist wie damals, wo ich gelernt habe, dass man sich sehr viele Gedanken machen soll über eine Überschrift bei Zeitungsartikeln. Hast du mal bei einer Zeitung gearbeitet? Ja, ja, genau. Und ich werde nicht müde, das zu erzählen, weil ich heute auch noch ... Oh, Florentina ist so schön, das ist so dieses Menschliche, was du rüberbringst heute. Ja, ich freue mich. Und da habe ich auch gelernt, das sind ja eigentlich, ist das nur ein Halbjazz eigentlich, boah, noch niemals Subjekt, bin ich gerade Objekt, du machst ja einfach ultra viele Gedanken, bei Betreff ist das genauso, weil das ist das erste, was dem Rezipienten ins Gesicht schlägt. Aber das ist für dich schon so ein Eyecatcher. Betreff auf jeden Fall, du kannst Leute auch dazu bringen, eine Mail zu öffnen, die sie eigentlich nicht öffnen wollen, indem du einfach einen anderen Betreff nimmst. Nur es wird dich verwirren, weil du kannst dann nicht nach dem Betreff suchen, wenn du denn in den Mails forschst. Was sind deine Betreffe so? Was machst du, kurze oder eher lange oder schreibst du einen Satz? Ich habe hier einmal Infomaterial anfordern als Betreff. Sehr geehrte Frau Fischer, ich möchte Infomaterial zur Bürgerinitiative Sauberer Himmel e.V. anfordern. Bitte schicken Sie das Material an meine Adresse. Beste Grüße, Florentin Will, besteeste Grüße. Du schickst sehr viele komische Mails, kann das sein. Mag ich auch tatsächlich beste Grüße. Mag ich auch ganz gern. Nicht nur gute Grüße, nicht nur freundliche Grüße, sondern die besten Grüße. Ist ein bisschen over the top, finde ich. Ist ein bisschen drüber. Könnt auch in ironischer. Aber hier auch, habe ich auch wieder geschrieben also Beste schreibe ich rechts aus. Ich hatte mal eine Phase, wo ich als Verabschiedung geschrieben habe, stets. Oh Gott, Gott sei Dank, hast du diese Phase überwunden. Stets, Florentin Will, fand ich aber auch nicht schlecht, irgendwie, weil das hat wir haben ein, ich finde, wir haben ein manchmal will man ja auch ein bisschen aus der Sache rausstehen. Stehen? Wir haben einen Kollegen von mir, auch von dir übrigens, der schreibt immer, was er gerade macht. Daraus macht er einen Partizipialverb und macht dann seinen Namen runter. Sowas wie dankend, hm, dankend Stefan. Oh ja, ich weiß. Abwartend Stefan. Abs Absolut, finde ich ganz nett. Sich drüber freuend, Stefan. Aber das ist für mich so das, und da möchte ich einen zweiten Begriff prägen, so ein bisschen das Halligalli-Phänomen, das Zirkus-Halligalli-Phänomen. Und zwar ist das beschreibende Zirkus-Halligalli-Phänomen für mich eine Struktur, aus der man nicht mehr rauskommt. Zirkus Halligalli hatte ja diesen Countdown in der ersten Folge, und ich glaube, die ersten fünf Folgen dachten die sich, was für eine geile Idee, aber so nach der zehnten Folge denken die sich, fuck, wir müssen uns jede Woche was Neues überlegen. Und es gibt auch nicht so viele Leute, die sind scheiße. Und wir wollen es ja auch nicht wiederholen. Und genauso ist es, glaube ich, auch mit so einer Art von Verabschiedung, dass du immer den Druck hast, jedes Mal was Neues zu überlegen und gut zu sein. Das ist viel Druck. Das glaube ich auch. Genau, und das ist das letztendlich, es impliziert so, dass man sehr kreativ sein will. Und immer eine andere Verabschiedung, sich freund, in den Himmel guckend, Stefan. Das ist irgendwie auch ein bisschen albern. Aber das ist ein netter Kerl. Aber ich finde, man sollte echt mal alte Mails drüber gehen.
Ich habe hier jemanden geschrieben, ich habe mal Thilo Bode interviewt, und das Interview ging komplett schief, und dann habe ich jemanden diese Erfahrung geschildert in einem kleinen Prosa-Text. Interessiert dich das? Wäre das was für dich, so eine kleine Geschichte? Ja, hau raus. Ich werde hier sitzen und mit grossen Augen im Schneidersitz die Geschichte annehmen. Jeden Tag starrt er mich an, von der Korbplatte über meinem Schreibtisch, die ich dort zur Präsentation von Gedächtnisstützen und Gusterstücker der Tagespresse installiert hatte, in seinem Fall ein Mahnmal. Ein Axel Springer Besucherausweis mit einem zur Fratze verzerrten Datum und dem Namen, der schon vor zwei Wochen jede meiner Googlesuchen begleitet hatte, Thilo Bode.
Er hatte ihm mir gereicht, nachdem wir ihn nach getaner Sache an den Haupteingang zurückgegleitet hatten, gereicht wie einen Fetzen Hoffnung an einen Gefallenen. Was dort gerade stattgefunden hatte, war ein Massaker, ein Hinterhalt, eine Abfertigung. Das erwartet man bei Monsanto-Funktionären, bei Regierungschef oder ÖlmMogulen, aber nicht bei ihm. Er ist einer von den Guten. Dieser Abend kann faszinieren, aber nur mit dem, was ihm fehlte. Es ging nicht um Lebensmittel, es geht um Demokratie. Damit stellte der Geschäftsführer der Verbraucherschutzorganisation Foodwatch die transparente Entscheidungsfreiheit der Konsumenten als Grundlage seiner Arbeit heraus. Jeder sollte kaufen dürfen, was er will, er müsse nur darüber aufgeklärt sein, was er denn da kauft und was er damit unterstützt beziehungsweise rechtfertig. Dafür setzt sich Bode ein, und wo der ein oder andere sich ja ganz gerne mal verarschen lässt und träumt die Kippe, Wecke, den Cowboy in ihm, so hört spätestens bei Kindern der Spaß auf, und schon hat er uns wieder. Meine Kollegen und ich sollten ihn interviewen, mal so richtig was aus ihm rauskitzeln. Doch war unser Starbucks getränkte Leitkulturskepsis seiner fünfzig Jahre gereiften Moralkeule nicht gewachsen. Was soll man denn den auch fragen? Warum machen sie nicht noch mehr Gutes? Könnten sie nicht noch etwas besser machen? Geschenkt. Kommt beim Kampf gegen die mächtige Lebensmittellobby nicht auch mal Verzweiflung auf? Mehrthörer-Status auf dem Silbertablett. Danke gerne, nächste Frage. Seit mit Wohltätigkeit der Ablasshandel neu entdeckt wurde und dicke Firmen lächelnd Laptops als Bildungsstütze an Entwicklungsländer reichen, denen das Kobalt für den Prozessor noch unter den Fingernägeln hängt, fragt man lieber zweimal nach, bevor jemand einfach nur helfen will. Was bringt für Sie dabei raus? Na, wie viel der Spendengelder fließt in Ihre Tasche? Sie
freuen sich doch bestimmt insgeheim, dass es Täuschungen in der Lebensmittelindustrie gibt,
sonst hätten Sie ja kein Geschäft. Ja, da ist was dran. Genau wie wir kein Geschäft hätten, wenn
jemand verdammt noch mal nichts falsch macht. Die Hufe des Hohen Rosses bohren sich in die,
die im tugendhaften Larifari des modernen Ja und Nein schwelgen.
So, liebe Leute, Magnete! Larifari des modernen Ja und Nein schwelgen.
So, liebe Leute, Magnete! Magnete! Ne, sehr schön. Hast du es geschrieben? Das habe ich geschrieben, ja. Wir hatten nämlich damals in der Frank-Elsa-Maser-Class, sollten wir immer jede Woche jemanden interviewen in der Gruppe, aber zwei Leute interviewen ihn und der Rest stellt Fragen, wie so eine Pressekonferenz. Und ich war der Erste, der zusammen mit einer Kollegin Thilo Bode interviewen sollte und das war eines der grössten Niederlagen der Welt, weil das war wirklich eine Katastrophe. Wie deine Joyce-Elite-Niederlage, die wir erzählen werden. Gleich, gleich, gleich. In der nächsten Folge. Ja, in der nächsten Folge. Das war wirklich eine Katastrophe. Nee, das glaube ich. Ich habe nämlich auch mal bei einer Zeit überarbeitet und da mussten wir nämlich auch Leute interviewen. Das ist gar nicht so einfach. Ne, ich habe einen Bundeswehroffizier interviewt, das habe ich aber sehr unangenehm wahrgenommen und dann habe ich auch so eine Lobeshymne nachher auf ihn geschrieben, weil er einfach diese Abzeichen hatte, diese ganzen und auch in Uniformen die ganze Zeit vor mir stand und das war so ein Rekrutierungstyp, der auch wirklich Leute rekrutiert halt dazu und ich war auch kurz davor, einfach mich einzuschreiben.
Ich bin absolut der Fall zu tief für so kritische Sachen, weil mich können Leute ganz schnell überzeugen, das merkst du ja auch mittlerweile. Ja, absolut.
Also man kann mich so schnell überzeugen und dann, ich war echt kurz davor, alles zu unterschreiben und ich habe so einen riesen Lobesum mit auf die geschrieben und in der Zeitung, ja, ganz netter Artikel, aber ein bisschen zu lieb, ne? Vor allem irgendwann interviewt er dich. Das ist immer das Schlimmste bei Interviews, wenn irgendwann der andere und du denkst, Moment mal, Hilfe! Für solche Kritiken, so kritisch angehauchte Texte bin ich einfach der falsche Typ, glaube ich. Apropos Magnete. Ich habe mir Folgendes überlegt. Warum macht man nicht vorne und hinten in Autos, so einer Stossstange, weißt du, Magnete rein, die sich bei anderen Autos abstossen würden? Das heißt, du kannst in Autos nicht mehr reinfahren. Auffahrumfälle würde es nicht mehr geben. Verstehst du das? Ja, so ein Trampolin-Effekt. Genau. Vorne im Auto und hinten im anderen Auto sind Magnete, die sich gegenseitig abstossen, dann gäbe es keine Auffahrunfälle mehr. Das wäre doch absolut genial. Könnte man aber noch weiterdenken eigentlich, so zum Beispiel Fahrradhelme oder sowas? Ja, warum genau? Da müsste der ganze Boden, aber... Das ist er ja früher oder später. Irgendwann ist ja alles aus Metall, machen wir uns nichts vor. Aber es muss auch möglich sein, andere Materialien zu magnetisieren. Ja, das macht auch wirklich … Wenn zumindest Hausböden so ein Nordmagnet sind und alle Sachen, die runterfallen, auch genordet sind. Also das ist quasi Nordpol und Südpol bei Magneten, auch wie ja jeder weiß. Und wenn Norden und Norden stürzt sich ja ab, genau wie Süden und Süden. Aber war das nicht so, dass auf der Weltkugel auf dem Südpol der Nordpol ist, magnetisch gesehen? Mhm, ja, weil irgendwie die Welt ist ein bisschen kreis. Da hat nicht mal jemand irgendwo einen Fehler gemacht und ist einfach falsch benannt. Nein, die Begründung ist, die Welt ist halt ein bisschen crazy. Absolut. Nee, vor allem, dass man auch diesen Anthropozentrismus, dass man wieder sagt, dass ... Der was? Die Welt offensichtlich Anthropozentrismus. Also, dass der Mensch natürlich fehlerfrei ist und die Erde offensichtlich einen Scheiss gebaut hat, weil offensichtlich der Nordpol der Südpol ist, anstatt zu sagen, der Mensch hat offensichtlich verkackt von Anfang an und ist einfach auf Falschrum benannt.
Du bist mental ausgestiegen.
Zum Thema unkreative Dinge, Weihnachtsmann ist sehr unkreativ, aber zum Beispiel, was auch sehr unkreativ ist, Neufundland. Also wer auch immer die Aufgabe hatte, das zu benennen, Maya, haben Sie das neue Land schon benannt? Ja, klar, natürlich, zum einen das Land, das wir neu gefunden haben, Neufundland, alles klar, machen wir. Auch ein Supersketch. Supersketch, ja, Tele 5, Leute, wetzt eure Kugelschreiber. Was ich auch noch lustig finde, das Eis, Nogga. Also, Leute. Auch so ganz nah am Verfassungsschutz vorbeigekratzt auch. Nogga. Leute, wir brauchen einen provokativen Namen, aber nicht zu provokativ. Wir haben ein braunes Eis, nennen wir es einfach Nogga. Nein. Nogga? Bist du dumm, du kannst doch ein Eis nicht Nogga nennen, bist du wahnsinnig? Okay. Nogga? Fantastisch, das nehmen wir. Sehr gut. Sehr gut, Müller. Sie sind befördert. Geil, sehr jung. Auch wenn sie sich mit einer lustigen Mail beworben haben, sie werden befördert. Lustige Mails, Leute, liebe Podcast-Ufuzuhörer, lustige Mails sind was für die anderen. Lustige Mails gehen immer nach hinten los. Und denkt mal darüber nach, was wir alles mit Magneten machen können. Stellen wir in der nächsten Woche vor. Sind wir schon durch eigentlich? Ich weiß nicht, ich bin tatsächlich ein bisschen dabei, gerade an Mails gucken, ob ich noch, hätte man tatsächlich eigentlich davor machen sollen, gebe ich jetzt ganz ehrlich zu. Sehr geehrte Frau Piep, ich bin Journalistenschüler und suche einen Interviewpartner aus dem Bereich Psychologie. Thema ist Wahrnehmungsverzerrungen, selektive Wahrnehmung und wie wir uns unsere Anliegen zu tun, zum Beispiel Verschwörungstheorie. Das Interview ist Teil eines Wissensformates. An wen kann ich mich für diese Anfrage wenden? Beste Grüße, Florentin Will. Lies doch du malstudium in Köln beginnt. Es ist absehbar, dass Sie in der Zeit vom Ende Juni einen Praktikanten suchen. Darüber hinaus würde ich gerne als journalistische Hilfskraft nehmen, am Studienarbeiten. Bieten Sie sowas auch an? Danke im Voraus und viele Grüße. Das ist so mein Ding. Danke im Voraus. Man denkt schon, man glaubt an das Gute im Menschen. Verabschiedungen sagen sehr viel über einen aus. Ach ja, und dann die tolle Antwort, lieber Herr Tietze, derzeit ist leider kein Patz frei, liebe Grüße. Das ist schon scheiße. Liebe Grüße noch hinterher, wo man sich einfach denkt, ja. Das ist sogar, dann habe ich hier, nee, nee, sonst ist es relativ unspektakulär. Vielen Dank nochmal für Ihre schnelle Antwort und viele Grüße, Stefan. Boah, das ist echt mein Ding, glaube ich. Verabschiedungen, vielen Dank, Stefan. Ja, Mails sind eigentlich ein Scheiß-Tema. Ich wollte eigentlich noch ganz kurz meine Milka-Mail anreißen, und zwar war das damals, ich weiß nicht, ob du dich erinnerst, aber wenn du heute in den Supermarkt gehst und dir Milka-Tafeln kaufst, haben die eine Plastikverpackung. Was? Früher hatten sie das nicht. Ja, ja, stimmt. Früher hatten sie eine Papierverpackung, und zwar noch um die Schokolade eine hauchdünne Alufolie herum und darüber dann eine Papierverpackung. Kannst du dich daran erinnern? Ja, tatsächlich. Und es war einmal etwas ganz Besonderes, weil Milka-Schokolade, dieses zarte Knistern der Alufolie, dieses kühle, die Schokolade war auch noch gekühlt und nicht geschmolzen und du hattest sie in der Hand und durch die Alufolie wurde es isoliert und das war ganz toll.
Und die Papier, mein Vater ist tatsächlich Milka Papierschokoladensammler. Ach, er sammelt verschiedene Papiere von verschiedenen Schokoladen und wenn es eine besondere Edition gab, zu Weihnachten hat er sich die gekauft. Und das Plastik jetzt auch noch? Oder ist es gestorben, das Hobby quasi? Na, Tess ist gestorben. Und genau das habe ich in der Mail an Milka geschrieben, habe ich gesagt, früher war das besser und es ist scheiße, dass sie das machen und sie hören überhaupt nicht mehr auf ihren Kunden. Da war ich irgendwie 15 oder so, irgendwie einen kompletten Schwachsinn geschrieben. Und da habe ich wirklich eine ellenlange Mail, die man wirklich mal veröffentlichen müsste, ellenlange Mail geschrieben und habe dann auch gesagt, so ja, hier, Sie kennen doch bestimmt die Geschichte von The New Coke, wo Coca-Cola eine neue Cola gemacht hat mit neuer Rezeptur und damit total gefloppt ist. Die Leute wollen nichts Neues, aber das haben Sie ja bestimmt in Ihrem Management-Seminar gelernt, ja, an den Kundensupport, ja, an irgendeiner Praktikantin, die da im Kundensupport sitzt. Und ich halt wirklich, das haben Sie ja bestimmt gelernt und das muss ich Ihnen ja nicht sagen. Als 15-Jähriger muss ich Ihnen das nicht sagen. Aber auch was für ein Selbstbewusstsein man hat. Das muss ich ja nicht sagen. Das haben Sie in Ihrem Management-Seminar gelernt, was auch immer das sein soll. Ein Management-Seminar zum Thema Schokolade. Ich habe mal, das war noch gar nicht so lange her, vor ein paar Monaten habe ich an Mentos geschrieben, auch ein bisschen wütend schon im Ton, warum sie Mentos Energy nicht mehr haben. Das war nämlich so eine Sorte, die wie Red Bull geschmeckt hat und unglaublich gepusht hat.
Eine Rolle, Mentos Energy hat irgendwie so die Wirkung von zwei Tassen Kaffee, glaube ich. Und die haben wir damals in der Schule immer gegessen. gegessen. Ich glaube, das war nicht so gesund und hat es auch wirklich relativ sehr geprägt, weil anscheinend ist es doch in meinem Kopf drin, dieses Bedürfnis danach, weil ich habe echt eine Mail schreiben müssen, ob es das noch gibt und warum sie es nicht mehr produzieren. Und es war irgendwie nur eine Marke, die in so ein Ding, was sie irgendwie nur ein Jahr gemacht haben, das war so eine Sonderedition. Echt scheiße. Aber da habe ich auch sofort ein Mailchen geschrieben. Und das würde man glaube ich nicht machen, wenn man nur die Möglichkeit hätte, anzurufen. Das ist so ein Ding, dafür sind Mails supergut. So Milka oder Mentor anschreiben. Hast du da eine Antwort bekommen? Ja, tatsächlich. Die finde ich vielleicht sogar noch. Aber können wir nicht da auch mal das zu einer Folge machen, dass wir bei solchen Verbraucher-Hotlines anrufen und uns beschweren, dass es gewisse Produkte nicht mehr gibt und andere schon, weil da gibt es einige. Ich nenne nur mal zum Beispiel als Beispiel die Trolley Cheesecakes. Trolley, diese Süßigkeitenfirma, die diese Gummigeschichten herstellt, hatte mal eine Reihe Cheesecakes, so kleine Stückchen Käsekuchen, aber natürlich so aus Gummi, wie Gummibärchen auch, aber die waren sehr gut. Die waren so ein bisschen schaumig, aber haben auch wirklich nach Käsekuchen ein bisschen geschmeckt, drei verschiedene Sorten in einer Packung, fantastisch, habe ich mir damals, glaube ich, eine ganze Kiste von gekauft, weil ich schon geahnt habe, dass es die irgendwann nicht mehr gibt und tatsächlich gibt es sie nicht mehr. Da würde ich gerne mal nachforschen, was da passiert. Ja, das stimmt, warte mal kurz. Ich habe sie gefunden. Ich habe geschrieben an die Kundensupportnummer, hallo zusammen, werden Mentos Energy noch produziert? Ich bin seit Jahren auf der Suche danach und kenne viele weitere, die ebenfalls verzweifelt danach sind. Das Internet ist ja auch voll von Verzweifelten. Oh, da habe ich einfach mal geschrieben, dass sie denken, dass sie damit Geld machen können. Ich habe jetzt die Hoffnung, dass man sie vielleicht direkt bei Ihnen kaufen kann. Vorab vielen Dank und mit freundlichen Grüßen Stefan. Dann kam zurück, hallo Stefan, vielen Dank für deine Anfrage vom 9. August und das damit verbundene Interesse an unserer Marke und den Mentos-Artikeln. Leider müssen wir dir mitteilen,
dass die Mentos-Sorte Energy ausschliesslich als limitierter Aktionsartikel und als Sorte
des Jahres 2007 vermarktet wurde. Aufgrund der insgesamt zu geringen Nachfrage wurde die
Produktion dieser Sorte danach eingestellt, Eine weitere Entführung ist nicht geplant. Eine koffeinaltige Sorte führen wir nicht mehr, aber sicherlich findest du unter der aktuellen verschiedenen Geschmacks... Nee, also habe ich nicht gefunden. Schade. Und sie legen mir... Ganz besonders möchten wir dir empfehlen, unsere neue Sorte Mentos Energy... Nee, Mentos Erdbeermix oder saure Früchte zu probieren. Wir bedauern dir, keine erfreulichere Mitteilung machen zu können. Wir fanden dich in grüssen auf Bonn. Als saure Früchte. Dein Mentos-Team. Tut mir leid, dass wir als Antwort nur saure Früchte haben und keine bessere Nachricht. Das ist scheiße. Die sind kacke. Saure Früchte ist nicht gut. Das ist auch vor allem nichts Neues. Das haben die schon ewig, saure Früchte. Ist aber eigentlich ein anderes Thema. Also so Produkte können wir auch mal machen, dann kann ich auch meinen Watch-Ever-Rant raushauen, weil ich habe letztens Watch-Ever gekündigt.
Das ist ultra scheiße, ne? Habe ich auch.
Weil tatsächlich muss man sich so ein Plug-in installieren, um wieder Videos anschauen zu können, aber anscheinend lässt sich dieses Plug-in nicht auf Chrome installieren.
So, jetzt gehst du davon aus, okay, installieren funktioniert nicht, du gehst auf die Watch-Ever-Seite, Frequently Asked Questions, und dann steht da als erstes, weil die Hälfte der Welt benutzt Chrome, steht da als erstes, kann ich das auf Chrome installieren? Nein, sie können Watch-Ever nicht mit Chrome benutzen. Steht da aber natürlich nicht, steht nirgendwo. Da steht, was soll ich machen, wenn es nicht funktioniert, löschen Sie Ihren Browserverlauf, bla bla bla, und anstatt die da einfach hinschreiben, Sie können mit Chrome, whatever nicht mehr benutzen, Punkt. Tut uns leid, Sie können hier Ihre Mail antragen, falls wir Sie informieren sollen, wann es wieder geht. Geil. Ich habe nicht gekündigt, weil es nicht mehr geht, sondern ich habe es gekündigt wegen der fucking FAQ, wo die das einfach nicht fucking hinschreiben konnten. Fucking, fucking, fucking. Weißt du, worauf ich... Da habe ich eine wütende Mail geschrieben und habe begrüßt mitüsst mit Hallo, und ich habe keine Verabschiedung gegeben. Boah, das war auch krass. Ich habe nämlich so eine Uni, wo jetzt irgendwie gerade erst das NRW-Ticket eingeführt wurde. Das heißt, ich kann jetzt durch NRW fahren und habe halt so einen bezahlbaren Jahresbeitrag und muss dann, kann halt kostenlos, also man muss nicht immer neue kaufen, dieses Ticket, man kann wirklich kostenlos in NRW rumfahren. Naja, nicht kostenlos, aber man hat halt, man muss nichts mehr draufzahlen. Und das ist wirklich echt ein gutes Ticket. Und ich habe aber aus dem letzten Jahr, weil es das dann noch nicht gab, habe ich noch eine Bahncard 50. Und die muss man irgendwie wirklich mehrere Monate im Voraus, muss man die kündigen, sonst werden die einfach verlängert. Aber richtig krass und so richtig, man wird auch nicht daran erinnert, man kriegt einfach dann so eine Mail, ja, herzlichen Glückwunsch, Sie haben wieder die Bahncard bestellt, 200 Euro stellen wir Ihnen hiermit in Rechnung. Und da war ich wirklich sauer drüber, weil die auch wenigstens die Eier haben können als so ein scheiß Staatsunternehmen, einem vorher daran zu erinnern und ein bisschen Bedienerfreund, Ministerfreundlicher zu sein, Konsumenten, Endverbrauchermässig zu denken. Damit kommst du nicht weiter. In der heutigen Welt, glaube ich, ist Kundenzufriedenheit ganz unbequem.
Da war ich richtig sauer.
Nur Profit, Profit, Profit.
Da habe ich einfach, um mich abzunehmen, ein bisschen wie so Boxack-mäßig, habe ich mir dann so fünf Leute angerufen,
also fünfmal beim Callcenter angerufen und die wirklich zu sauer gemacht.
Einfach um mich mal in diesem Moment abzureagieren, weil es wirklich scheiße ist. Warst du noch auf der Anrufannahme? Wurde dein Anruf angenommen oder nicht? Er wurde angenommen, wahrscheinlich von der Frau, die wir schon kennengelernt haben in der ersten Folge. Die du belästigt hast, muss man mal so sagen. Ja, was ich auch noch sagen wollte. Heute Abend ist ein ganz besonderer Abend, und zwar heute am 23. Dezember gehe ich auf ein Abitur-Jahrgangsstufen-Treffen. Das ist krass. Das erste. Ich glaube fünf Jahre, vier Jahre nach meinem Abitur, ich weiß es ehrlich gesagt gar nicht, sowas in der Richtung, alle treffen sich wieder, nee, 2010 habe ich Abi gemacht, also vor ungefähr vier Jahren. Ja, ich bin gespannt, was da alles auf mich zukommt. Hast du sowas schon mal gemacht? Nein, nein, aber bei mir ist das noch gar nicht so lange her. Also bei mir hätte sich nicht geändert. Alle würden nämlich studieren, manche hätten angefangen abzubrechen und angefangen abzubrechen. Ja, aber es haben soweit ich weiß, haben schon ein paar geheiratet. Echt jetzt? Ja, es gibt auch glaube ich schon ein paar Kinder. Was? Ich bin mir sicher, vielleicht. Nein. Es ist, glaube ich, niemand gestorben. Prom Night, Prom Night Babies. Ist keiner gestorben? Das ist ja das, was mich immer interessiert. Wann stirbt der Erste aus dem Abi-Jahrgang? Weil... Dass keiner gestorben ist, ist statistisch, glaube ich, relativ unwahrscheinlich. Eben, ich glaube nämlich auch, wenn man, das sind irgendwie, weiss ich, 100 Leute oder was, 200 Leute oder sowas in der Richtung, und da muss doch irgendwie nach ein paar Jahren, nach vier Jahren muss doch da einer gestorben sein. Also ich warte nur darauf. Als andere wäre ein Skandal. Also ich werde da heute auch mal investigativ nachforschen, wie kann es sein, dass noch niemand von euch tot ist? Du musst heute fünf Leute fragen, warum eigentlich noch keiner gestorben ist und ob man das nicht, warum er das nicht verhindern konnte. Ach, willst du mir Aufgaben geben oder was? Ja, weiß ich nicht genau.
Was ist ein Dresscode? Habt ihr einen Anzug
an? Nein, überhaupt nicht. Das ist komplett leger.
Wo macht er das? In irgendeinem
Café, glaube ich, würde komplett... Kegelbahn.
Kegelbahn.
Aber es ist natürlich immer so die Frage, wie man sich da
verhält. Also viele... Du wirst
angeben. Ich glaube, du wirst allen auf die Nase binden,
dass du beim Fernsehen jetzt bist.
Aber das glaube ich eben nicht. Ich glaube, aber das ist die Frage, wie man das macht. Man will natürlich Dinge erzählen, die ungewöhnlich sind, weil das interessant ist, man will aber auch nicht Dinge erzählen, die zu ungewöhnlich sind, weil die Leute damit nichts anfangen können. Wenn ich jetzt sage, hey, wisst ihr, damals total krass irgendwie, wir waren da im Studio und bei der Mikrofonprobe. Und dann kam Joyce Ilk. Ist dann Joyce Ilk gekommen und dann ist der Scheinwerfer ausgefallen und der Regieassistent meinte dann so, hey Leute, wir müssen mal zurück auf die Eins und ich so, what, auf die Eins, was ist das denn? Also das ist manchmal echt krass, wenn ich sowas erzähle, dann blickt ja keiner durch. Genau, nimmst du das auch so wahr, ich würde auch gerne mal so Sachen erzählen aus dem Produktionsalltag, weil das auch wirklich lustige Dinge sind, aber die meisten können es nicht nachvollziehen. Versteht niemand, versteht niemand. Und man kann es auch nicht so erklären, um jetzt alle ins Boot zu holen, das geht einfach nicht. Und deswegen ist es glaube ich so, dass Produktionsfirmen oft so ein ganz eigener Kosmos sind, wo die untereinander die Leute ultra gut klarkommen, ultra lustig miteinander können, aber ausserhalb ist es ultra schwierig, Leute damit irgendwie einzubinden. Es ist glaube ich so. Und deswegen musst du heute Abend irgendwie versuchen, den Mittelweg zu finden. Ich glaube, es wird auch immer schwerer, weil sich ja die Lebensrealität von den Menschen immer weiter auseinanderlebt. Also vor vier Jahren waren wir alle noch gleich, gleiche Sachen angeschaut, gleiche Sachen gemacht, irgendwie so ein bisschen sehr ähnliches Leben geführt. Aber mittlerweile, der eine war irgendwie lange Zeit im Ausland, der andere ist jetzt Arzt, der andere ist jetzt arbeitslos, der andere hat dreimal geheiratet, der andere ist tot. Ja, was will man denn mit sich mit dem unterhalten? Ist natürlich auch schwierig, wie man da rangeht. Ich finde auch lustig, wenn du mit so einer Haltung da rangehen würdest, als wäre das irgendwie erst vor 30 Jahren schon gewesen. Ja. Und man erwartet so riesen Biografien und man will schon, dass der eine irgendwie festgenommen wurde dreimal und so. Absolut, ja, vor allem, ich glaube, die Frage ist, wie die anderen da rangehen, weil ich gehe natürlich an diese Sache so, als wäre es eine Folge in einer Sitcom, so, das Klassentreffen. Und dann hat man als Zuschauer, wenn du irgendwie anschaust Community oder Arrested Development und eine Folge heißt das Klassentreffen, hast du bestimmte Erwartungen. Du willst, dass irgendjemand abstürzt, du willst, dass Leute angeben, du willst, dass einer wahnsinnig erfolgreich ist, du willst, dass einer total der Arsch ist, du willst gucken, was ist aus den früher gewordenen, die die früher gemobbt haben, was ist aus den Nerds geworden, wahrscheinlich ist einer der Nerds jetzt der Chef von allem, der die gemobbt hat, irgendwie sowas, Wendung des Schicksals, irgendwie sowas in der Richtung, man will angeben und oh, das Arschloch und so, also ich gehe da total ran um und ich will alle Klischees erfüllen. Ich will heute Abend alle Klischees erfüllen. Ich will irgendwie, ich will einen dummen Kommentar machen, ich will irgendwie sagen von wegen, oh, zum Glück, keine Ahnung, habe ich ja noch kein Kind, das ist total scheiße und dann steht eine mit dabei, die schon ein Kind hat und fragt, wie meinst du das und es wird eine unangenehme Stille geben. Sowas in der Richtung, ich will heute alle Klischees erfüllen. Hast du denn noch viel Kontakt zu den Leuten oder hast du auch noch viele Freunde damals, mit denen du noch Kontakt hast? Ja, doch, das schon. Also da habe ich schon noch einige Freunde, aber mit denen, mit denen ich auch in der Schule nicht viel Kontakt habe, habe ich jetzt natürlich noch weniger Kontakt, logischerweise. Ach so, das ist interessant. Aber zum Beispiel wurde da eine Facebook-Gruppe gegründet für alle Leute des Jahrgangs und da wurden dann halt so organisatorische Sachen geschrieben und meine erste Reaktion war natürlich, ich lasse ein paar Gags raus, ja, ich schreibe ein paar Gags, aber das ist natürlich ein sehr schwieriges Publikum, weil manche Leute, mit denen hat man sich damals schon nicht verstanden, jetzt sind die noch weiter weg und ich wollte so Sachen schreiben wie, hatte ich tatsächlich auch schon ins Facebook-Feld eingetragen und ich hätte es fast abgeschrieben, ich wollte schreiben so, hey, ich dachte, solche Geschichten finden eigentlich erst so in zehn Jahren statt, wenn wir richtig was zu erzählen haben. Naja, egal, kann ich meine drei Ex-Frauen auch mitbringen? So, ja, kleiner Gag, nicht der Beste der Welt, da gebe ich ganz ehrlich zu. Aber einfach mal, verstehst du, get the ball rolling, ja, einfach mal so ein bisschen sagen, das ist keine ganz so ernste Angelegenheit, wir können ein bisschen Spaß machen, wir können selbstironisch auf die Situation blicken, ja, aber habe ich dann doch nicht geschrieben und ich bin so froh, ich bin so froh, dass ich das nicht geschrieben habe. Und das unterscheidet dich von mir, weil ich hätte das natürlich abgeschickt, aber ich hätte noch einen schlechteren Gag abgeschickt. Das ist mir egal, sowas, ey, und im Nachhinein bereue ich es immer. Aber dafür bin ich einfach zu unkönnen. Aber sowas geht immer in die Hose. Immer, immer. Ich habe zum Beispiel auch, bevor die Masterclass angefangen hat, haben wir schon eine Facebook-Gruppe gegründet, um uns so ein bisschen kennenzulernen. Und auch da, man kennt sich ja überhaupt nicht. Der eine ist irgendwie 20 Jahre älter als mein andere, der andere spricht kein Deutsch. Man ist da wirklich wahnsinnig weit auseinander. Und auch da wollte ich schon so... Weil ich habe immer so eine Metaperspektive auf gewisse Dinge. Ich sehe das immer so, als wäre es eine Folge in einer Serie. Und habe dann geschrieben so, haha, freue mich schon auf das ganze Drama, wer von euch ist denn die Zicke? So, ne, weil es in der Serie immer, in der Serie gibt es immer eine Zicke, so wie bei Germany's Next Topmodel. Ja, aber du musst dir ja Leute ja auch wieder ins Boot holen, bei diesen Gedanken.
Du hast ja keinen anderer, kein Mensch. Nein, aber auch da dachte ich, dass ich sozusagen mit anspielen will, als wären wir wie eine Boy-Group gecastet worden, damit die Sache möglichst interessant und medial ausschlachtbar wird. Was waren die Reaktionen? Masterclass. Die Reaktion war nichts, kein Like, null. Und als wir uns das erste Mal getroffen haben, meinte auch eine, wie hast du das denn gemeint mit der Zicke? Oh ja, fuck. Und da wurde mir erst mal klar, was ich überhaupt angestellt habe. Und ich so, nein, nein, nur mit dem Gang so, naja, ist aber ganz schön mutig, bevor man die Leute kennt, dann irgendwie von Zicke zu reden. Ich habe niemanden direkt als Zicke bezeichnet, es war nur ein Witz, aber vergete ich. Du kommst bei Leuten einfach nicht durch die Humormauer, du kommst nicht durch. Ne, genau, und es ist doch so, man denkt an Leuten, man kennt die Leute, die du heute Abend da triffst, weil du hast ja auch eine Grossteile deines Lebens mit denen verbracht, und deswegen ist heute viel Peinlichkeitspotential da, weil du könntest ja, man redet mit denen so, als würde man sie Jahre kennen, aber mittlerweile trennt euch wirklich schon vier Jahre, trennt euch, trennen euch und deswegen glaube ich, dass man wirklich wieder von null anfängt eigentlich, was die Gags angeht. Das sind die Fremde auf eine Art. Ja, entweder das oder man setzt genau da an, wo man aufgehört hat. Die Pointe bringt man doch direkt zu dem letzten Gag, den man damals vor vier Jahren gebracht hat.
Ich schau grad nach, was es kostet, einen Lamborghini für einen Tag zu mieten. Das ist mein einfaches Lamborghini-Vorfahr. Was? Es kostet 700 Euro, einen Lamborghini zu mieten für einen Tag. Was glaubst du denn? Hallo? Ja. Einen Tag? Aber aber du erkennst haben die nicht auch dann so rote nummernschilder und das lügengebäude kippt ganz schnell in sich zusammen genau steht jetzt so ganz gross Sixt auf der Seite und dann kommst du mit so einem Lieferwagen an von Sixt um ganz rosa ich aber noch lustiger, ehrlich gesagt. Den Kind würde wahrscheinlich aber auch nie verstehen. Hat jemand mal versucht, so richtig schlecht wegzukommen an so einem Abend? Ich glaube nicht. Hat jemand mal versucht, mit so einem Wohnwagen sich so mieten und dann anzukommen? Hat das jemand mal jemand versucht? Das fände ich echt so lustig. Das fände ich lustiger mal. Einfach nicht, alle wollen immer versuchen, gut wegzukommen, mal scheiße wegkommen. Und dann mit so einem Lieferwagen ankommen, wo man irgendwie auf der Ladefläche schläft oder so. Und dann mit so einem Pickup-Truck. Genau, ja. Das ist meine Frau, wir schlafen auf dem Pickup-Truck. So ganz verkommene Kinder, die man mitnehmen muss, weil die Frau tot ist oder so. Hat das jemand mal versucht? Ich glaube nicht. Ich glaube, ich werde Folgendes machen. Diese Treffen wird es jetzt wahrscheinlich häufiger geben. Ich werde versuchen, heute Abend extrem eloquent und reich und gut rüberzukommen, ich miete mir noch einen Wrack und alles und einen Lamborghini, aber beim nächsten Mal, im nächsten Jahr, das komplette Gegenteil, irgendwie Wohnwagen, schlechte Kleidung, ich stinke, ich habe vier Kinder. Und die Leute erfinden dann so Geschichten über dich, warum das alles passieren konnte, der unter anderem das Florentin will. Ich habe gehört, der hat irgendwie seine Wettschulden, ganz viele Wettschulden, der hat gespielt, spielsüchtig, sowas. Genau, ich versuche dann da, Drogen zu verticken, irgendwie ein bisschen Geld zu verdienen. Eigentlich bräuchte man viel mehr Vorbereitung für sowas. Ich bin erst heute Morgen aufgewacht und dachte, ah ja, cool, das könnte man ja lustig machen, aber zu spät. Man muss das eigentlich länger planen. Falls ihr Ideen habt, schickt sie einfach an zentrale-podcast-u-vom.fail. Oh Gott, das ist die schlechteste E-Mail-Adresse. Eigentlich ist sie sehr geil. Aber das Punkt Fail war die 80 Euro nicht wert im Monat. Naja. Nun gut. Stefan. Naja gut, wir sind auch durch jetzt heute, ne? Ich wünsche dir frohe Weihnachten. Ich wünsche dir auch. Weißt du was, wir müssen nächstes Mal mal eine Redeuhr, also eine Schachuhr einführen irgendwie. Und dann hat jeder von uns eine halbe Stunde Redezeit und wenn deine Redezeit abgelaufen ist, dann muss der andere halt monologisieren. Wieso hast du das Gefühl, dass du nicht genug geredet hast? Ne, ich habe das Gefühl, dass du, du bist halt irgendwann so drin und so und man kommt da nicht so gut zwischen. Aber ist nicht so schlimm. Du kannst gern noch einen zehn Minuten Monolog halten. Ja, aber das will ja keiner hören. Ich spiele jetzt Weihnachtsmusik ein und will von dir nochmal einen Abschlussmonolog. Ich mach eine Abschlussmoderation mal. Im Namen des gesamten Teams des Podcast-Ufos, Florentin Will und mir, wünsche ich allen, allen Zuhörern eine besinnliche Weihnachtszeit. Feiert schönen Weihnachten mit euren Familien, mit euren Liebsten und euren Familien. Und ich wünsche euch einen schönen, und Florentin sicherlich auch, einen schönen ersten Weihnachtsfeiertag, einen schönen zweiten Weihnachtsfeiertag. Kommt gut rein, jetzt nächste Jahr, sind wir da vorhin noch mal auf Sendung? Ja, wahrscheinlich, ne? Vor Silvester sind wir nochmal auf Sendung. Florentin? Hast du abgestaltet?
Komm, das war jetzt nur eben so gesagt. Wir müssen nicht mit dem Monolog halten. Monolog ist was für Nachrichtensprecher. Und nächste Woche ganz tolle Sachen. Ja, soll ich jetzt reden oder nicht? Wir machen noch die Joyce-Geschichte, erzählt Florentin, das ist die beste Geschichte, die ihr jemals gehört habt.
Das ist unfassbar so lust ihr jemals gehört habt.
Das ist unfassbar so lustig und so vielschichtig, diese Geschichte.
Dann machen wir Nachruf, schreiben wir für noch bald sterbende Leute.
Und ja, mal sehen, was wir noch so auf.
Wir rufen Produkt-Hotlines an.
Ich wünsche euch eine schöne Weihnachtszeit.
Ich euch auch. Macht's gut.
Tschüss.